[Music]
two guys we are here and we are so
excited excited
[Music]
[Applause]
this is my favorite episode of the year
and mine too this is our last episode of
the year in the studio before our break
and it is our annual sound bite
tournament
[Applause]
now our two previous year oh by the way
today's episode is sponsored by my
favorite e-commerce website Adam and Eve
did you know Ela that they sell lotions
and Bath and Body Works stuff okay Adam
and Eve my favorite e-commerce let's go
yeah
let's go I want to do a read for them
that's about like shampoo
anyway
um we honor basically the greatest of
all time the first winner of all time
was um
what was it
was it um I know five percent one last
year shout out to their family oh yeah
yeah duh of course David Guetta shout
out to his family was our first grand
champion and well deserved and five
percent swept the whole thing even
though there was an embargo
but here today we are here to choose our
new champion and is it a coincidence
that FIFA World Cup is happening at the
same time the world The Real World Cup
is happening here today on the 8th
Street Puck there's no such thing as
offensive I was gonna say that there
isn't
it beat me through it Zach also I want
to give a big thank you to some psycho
in our chat yeah
um let me open the chat he's been going
gangbusters on the gifted Subs
uh what's his name 100 his name's really
100 DPI yes sir why is the internet like
not loading for me oh you got to connect
to the right Network which I'm not going
to say on copy that
yeah so thank you to um
100 DPI who's A Gifted basically
everyone in the chat 800 gifted
I don't know man
thank you bro that's crazy dude you just
you you immediately
before the show even started became our
our Prime Saudi benefactor I think
you've dethroned
our Saudi benefactor yeah
um well let's we got some stuff at the
top of the show and then we're just
gonna get into it you know these
episodes are long and hard fought but I
got I gotta say there's some really
Heavy Hitters in this year's bracket
unbelievable I know a lot of people have
been expressing
some favorites do we want to discuss
favorites potentially do you have any
any you want to I'm curious to like
review everything you guys put together
because my memory of this year is like
half like non-existent I don't know like
Mom fog and like pregnancy
yeah I got you so also you're only here
once a week where we're getting that
[ __ ] hammered in our brains but I still
live by sound bites and repeat them at
home and think it that's good
that's what that's what real fans do
this show
but actually we even have an honorable
mention because we couldn't we had such
a hard time narrowing it down to 32.
we have 25 honorable mentions that we'll
go through okay well we have a video
package from them actually oh a very
nice uh oh well that's immemorium for uh
that's the Army yeah so before we get
started at that um
want to say that if you're trying to buy
some Teddy fresh Before Christmas you
can probably still do it
but it's getting close
don't if you're outside America is not
happening I would not take Ethan's
that's not a guarantee statements I'm
Teddy fresh as actuals it's not a
guarantee but there's a good shot like
I'll just be honest I mean you'll
probably get it before the 24th because
our support didn't have actual the
actual info that I did not know you
would want to mention I could have asked
them oh wow what the real date is well
I'm giving you like a like a
non-committal maybe we won't not
official yeah I mean what could go wrong
there
we have a lot going on uh I have a
headache and we got we got kids I'm
hungry we didn't have a babysitter
it's the longest day ever
yeah Dustin if kids are good for
anything at least it's getting out of
whatever you want
I mean that's the benefit to having kids
that you can never deny
well
where did that one come from that would
be Nick Fuentes literally saying when I
was a kid like when I was a kid and
everyone was like kids loved Hitler yeah
remember the days the good old days
where the [ __ ] you grow up brother yeah
but um yeah there's all kinds of fun
stuff so gift ideas uh maybe we'll show
up maybe it won't depends where you live
depends how we're feeling that day
uh but the taper street jacket all kinds
of fun stuff is here I love this one I
was wearing it yesterday
emotional support by Gary Kennedy thank
you will you're in the bracket this year
by the way
this one is awesome it's still available
beautiful piece absolutely love this one
lots of love for this piece and this one
gorgeous
it's all happening at teddyfresh.com
this is the one Brett Rockman was
rocking Brett well I said it right no
you're good it's like you cannot say it
right his name doesn't make sense he's
got it backwards I think you've got it
back I think you got it yeah because
bretman's not a name yes clearly it is
it's his name yeah Rock wait what I
think what I call him Brett because
Brett's the name right yeah man on its
own is a different name it's a totally
different thing well whatever in a
different vibe he was slaying in uh our
winter collection
you posted today I'll show you here he
is wait that's not rock man that's
Mega Man his original name is Rockman
you know really in Japan oh guys I guess
I need to get signed into Instagram next
he won't let me oh Lord
but yes he was rocking it and I love him
yeah so and also cam was oh yeah yeah
I already closed Instagram but yeah you
looked great in that one dude it was
very nice I'm humbled you guys let me do
that thank you very much hey it's our
pleasure come on now Cameron is very
nice he is very he's a nice he really is
one of the nicest guys you'll ever meet
Cameron that is true I was confused
because it uh that laptop is locked into
Instagram but apparently all of us got
logged out of that account hopefully we
didn't get banned
oh because I just went to pull it up on
my computer I'm also logged out here I
don't know what happened so I guess I
did something you know what it was there
it is
wait are you in a b no I'm logged on to
it I know I know I know we changed
something the other day okay okay good
I'm I'm still on we didn't get hacked by
the way and so I want to say though yeah
this is our last episode in the studio
for the year yeah so crazy Tuesday is
our big live show which we are telling I
just want to again emphasize is live for
everybody it starts the show starts at
seven or eight it starts at eight uh
Pacific it's going to be at an unusual
time and it's gonna be on Tuesday at
eight plus the evening so it's gonna be
pretty late if you're on the East Coast
but it's gonna be worth staying up for
if you want to watch it live it's going
to be on the channel anyway but it's
going to be so much freaking fun we have
got so much do some fun stuff planned
can I make a little PSA about the live
show for those who are planning on
attending in person who got tickets
um highly thank you this is some
breaking news uh highly recommend
um taking some sort of uh ride share or
public transportation to get to The
Venue the parking situation there is a
little rough so uh there is places to
park but a lot of it's like street
parking and like a neighborhood nearby
and stuff and um there's no like car
there's no there's no Big Lot that the
venue itself owns there's some around
but it's kind of a busy area highly
recommend taking an Uber or Lyft or
something like that taxi there's also a
subway stop yes very close by uh yeah
actually directly across the street
right uh it's like right there also if
you want to buy merch it's going to be
cash only we try to get a POS system
I'm sorry about that we are talking
about doing like a sample sale
yeah no we're going to have a sample
sale for our live show we have like a
ton of
samples and Top Productions of uh Teddy
fresh stuff and we have like a ton of it
just in storage here so we're gonna
bring a bunch of it and we're just gonna
have a big bags for everyone to just pay
like 20 bucks or something and take
whatever they want something like that
so you know buyer sale it'd be insane
and fill it up
but I think we'll do that we're gonna do
more live shows and assuming I don't
fall off the stage like Kelsey Grammer
or something
I think it'll be fun yeah
so anyway I'm excited to see you guys
all on a Tuesday wow it's coming up I
can't believe it yes sir yeah but I also
I I wanted to make one point clear to
our members I will be continuing to see
you next Tuesday podcast through the
break so it's a better time to be a
member than ever I am not fully
abandoning you guys only partially right
and then we'll be back mid January so
that's that
but enough about that stuff we've got
the show of the Year here to get to
right
um
although
I know who this is it's gay baby my boy
wow hey Gabe we're gonna see you on
we're seeing Gabe on Tuesday right
oh wow we'll see you at the live show on
Tuesday Gabe Epic
made a snowy Christmas tree baby fake
snow and then angel on top yeah
guys God bless you and
God bless you and I love that how'd you
get the fake snow on there yeah
we just have some like
I spray can some kind of spraying can
and oh that's so cool did you spray
looks like a wintry did you spray it
outside or in the living room yeah
we sprayed outside let's bring it in and
stuff yeah that's cool that's smart
that's cool man what do you got are you
um
are you ready to get in the holiday
spirit are we getting all cheery is it
that time yet
yes yes yes are you were you a good boy
this year Gabe
we'll see we'll see something tells me
you worry yeah no cold forget it never
never never
all right um well I'm excited to see on
Tuesday we're gonna have a nice
enthusiastic crowd who's all going to be
really excited to see you there I myself
included
sure you have to be a big surprise on
Tuesday
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all
right hey Gabe um mother Mary [ __ ] in my
mouth
[Music]
can we do some Christmas themed
well like a jeez Jesus Jesus turned your
[ __ ] to bread and feed me baby
[ __ ] yeah
can I get you yeah it doesn't seem that
eager to default
are you religious game
um a little bit okay
basic rules of goodness goodness from
the heart okay that's a goodness
[Applause]
so you but you're not yeah you don't
want to desecrate Jesus's name today
nah you're good man upstairs yeah we
don't
out of respect
all right in fact the man up there or
bad luck's gonna happen no we don't want
that we don't want that yeah no all
right Gabe well um I'm glad to see
you're getting into into the holiday
spirit and I'm just so excited to see on
Tuesday
and uh all right we're gonna have so
much fun it's gonna be nice to see you
and uh
and uh well I guess that's it so uh have
a great weekend okay bud
all right Merry Christmas God bless and
um
Merry Christmas
happy holidays
happy Holidays happy holidays
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're so good you're the man dude all
right we'll see you on Tuesday all right
that's my club game everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah white clock Gabe you can see him on
cameo
[Music]
speaking of which did we watch the one
where he was the chronic illness one we
did already yeah he had a really good
one where he was oh my God I don't know
what you're talking about it was good
yeah by the way we cut we put out the
call for people to
um start hyping up love and the media
did you see I didn't know you were gonna
do that
we're just we're doing it because it may
or may not yeah yeah yeah
but KFC Sweden they've heard you this we
they heard you like fried chicken and
you do I think you are passionate about
it right love so this is legit we love
chicken yeah
I love chicken fried chicken it's KFC in
Sweden good they it hits hard you know
what I think like chicken is the reason
I like it is because we're so deprived
of good fried chicken
yeah like there's just a couple KFC
stars in Sweden and it recently opened
in my city so it's perfect there's gonna
be more and more after this I actually
recorded this video before you made that
announcement oh really yeah so how did
this come together yeah I used to work
at this place like a co-working office
and I used to eat dinner with all these
high uh level marketers whatever and uh
I had asked for free gift cards before
it's not Shameless but and then just
randomly he he messaged me like oh we
something fell through can you come come
through to the office and record with
some tick tocks and I was like [ __ ] yeah
and yeah
so you have on your credentials
um chicken connoisseur chicken experts
you know some would say could you call
him a brand ambassador definitely well
yeah definitely yeah that's the official
tickets
you're basically Colonel Sanders
pretty much yeah let's watch this
yeah
damn I like the hoodie yeah
it's kind of almost a little bit awkward
no it's like ASMR I like it yeah it's
real the sound quality is insane crispy
strips extra crispy yeah or perfecto
it works because it made me want chicken
really bad yeah it does make the main
color oh that's okay that's great that's
well we're gonna we were gonna order
food so KFC is an option if y'all want
to get weird and wild in honor of you
know
disgusting you know I didn't want I
didn't want to be all all Shameless I
made sure to wear it to the fresh that
was the name thank you
don't worry it's only one thought that
one you're good listen yeah I wore the
color Block in the other one to even
represent there's another one yeah but
it's not publisher listen as we go into
the holiday season
you know I I give garyvee a hard time
for his nft collections for making out
with his dad although you know I got
boys and I you know I love my boys I
mean I kiss them on the lips but
I mean he's not the only one uh uh uh
what's his name young gravy not young
gravy the famous football player
Tom Brady damn near made out with this
all right on video yeah yeah right yeah
he did so but anyway here as we go into
holiday season what he said here really
resonated in me about um
perspective
so hopefully y'all can take something
away from this everybody look look at
your phone right now now put that phone
down
and
get into a handstand or some weird
position and look at it again and now
stand on your table and look at it again
it's going too fast and now go 15 steps
away and look at it again look at your
phone
different perspectives this is a
perspective game
I hope that's what we accomplished for
one person who's not in the right
perspective everybody looking so there
it is I hope everyone
just look at your phone
from different angles he has never done
that in his life dude he literally just
never he didn't even know where that was
going when he opened his mouth
I'm uh I'm officially out
that that ruined yeah he could kiss his
dad all he wants he could scam people
all he wants
that was too much but what's interesting
is this is yeah that's some very brave
of you Cam are you out putting everyone
to the test here I was never really in
but okay yeah
yeah I was kind of in yeah
listen after I after I imagine my family
getting killed yeah
yeah that kind of ruined it oh but he's
so he's so deep and I'm not saying
listen you come like garyvee you don't
have to choose me or him I'm just saying
if you do like garyvee you gotta do this
okay you better do a handstand look at
your phone right now look at it now put
that phone down
okay and
get into a hand
s
hold the [ __ ] up
he just changed my perspective on him
um all right there you go
perspective
soon he's still the master five these
chats dude he's the king hey that is
what he's saying like if you yes can't
see how dumb this is you gotta like
analyze your perspective on everything
oh my God
it could be
it could be that he's trying to weed out
the dumbest people possible and then
sell them nft yeah right right like that
and that is actually a marketing stress
oh
oh that's interesting too so but that
doesn't interesting here well put that
phone down
and
get into a handstand or some weird
position and he's confused by his
instructions yeah
delivery he's trying to land this [ __ ]
he doesn't know where he's going I'm
trying to think but nothing happened now
stand on your table and look at it again
and now go 15 steps away and look at it
again look at your phone different
perspectives yeah there's a perspective
dude I can't believe that this is a new
sound bite different perspectives
we all have to enter it for next year
but it is good Zach
and what's interesting is this account
is like on it's like a simp account like
super motivational and stuff and really
and it's apparently
yeah mad happy apparently that clip
really uh
really drove at home right now it's like
are they they're roasting him oh okay
yeah
they're saying this is what people who
make Gary Vee meme say bro's just saying
words Gary's just saying anything now
bro what are you saying me talking to my
boys after second blinker in 20 minutes
I don't get what's a blinker that's a
drug reference yeah it's uh let me see
what it is I forget oh this is good
sometimes I start a sentence and I don't
know where it's going Michael Scott
he sounds like he's trying to do a like
a garyvee parody impression oh my God
totally
oh it's a it's a it's a dab
just blasted out of your mind yeah so
there's garyvee everybody and uh he is a
great think of our time and actually go
if you go to Gary V and Friends
you can buy some of his exclusive nfts
for
stupid amount of money by the way any
updates on his restaurant where only V
friends can get in uh let me look I
haven't heard anything he was making an
nft only restaurant in New York love
that you still have to pay for it by the
way
it's not like
it's not like you pay with nfts or what
well you bought so you buy one of his
super expensive nfts and then you can
get into the restaurant to pay for super
expensive food oh
it's all somehow like surrounding some
sort of a scam I feel like yeah he's
he's all my opinion yeah yeah I mean
people
oh okay Garrett says I'm doing a
handstand on my toilet right now looking
at my phone
and he thinks maybe Keem isn't such a
bad guy yeah New Perspective
New Perspective maybe I need a jewel pod
[Applause]
Oh Aaron says wish my boyfriend Mordecai
that's like the coolest name ever wait
you have no problem with Mordecai but
but brentman was too far no it's not
that like it's like Mordecai I've heard
that's an iconic name I know right I I
ever met someone anyone named [ __ ] I
never met anyone right oh actually I did
in Israel but not in America
I just heard it's in media it's like the
only in the bangers and my hair oh why
is this what a mordecai sounds like yeah
is it Mordecai from uh uh Sherlock
Holmes isn't that like the bad guys no
that's Moriarty oh Moriarty okay my bad
way cooler way cooler marzel said uh
this Show's gotten me through tough
times
and now my 18 year old brother passed
away what damn
I'm sorry yo I'm about to yell at you
like that twitch streamer I couldn't
help but think of that because it's in
the dock for today actually that's a
good segue but uh Marshall wow that's
that's horrible I'm so sorry I'm glad
that we're over to here and
that's what the family's for but damn I
can't imagine but she says she says and
this is important you are loved and
valued and are supposed to be here no
matter what
damn that's really sad yeah well um
actually another one y'all stop donating
I'm trying to do a show tried getting
Jimmy Lee Cameo for my friend but he was
too busy
I know that
little baby we've talked about it yeah
you know wait how much what does he do
on these cameos he rose people right
right I remember but he said he said
some like horrible anti-small people
thing
that's where that came he posted
something terrible this morning and I
actually I never interact with his
account but I actually responded and
told him he [ __ ] sucks oh wait wait
wait it was the oh give me the link give
me the link I saw it too I don't think
we shouldn't show it why if it's
actually he's just been super oh yeah
he's maybe he's sexually harassing
somebody he may be borderline committing
a crime yeah what is he doing can you
just describe it's an old-timey crime oh
my God the comments were a little too
old timey with this one the Jersey
Lawman would never do this that's true
uh he went up to a girl in the street
and he said something about he asked if
she was Japanese and she said no I'm
Chinese
you'll be on your knees and she's like
what what does that mean is she like
clearly offended and then he like keeps
saying it he's like come on baby yeah no
it's like really bad she said she said
what does that mean because she wanted
to be like say what you're saying yeah
she was like calling him out and he's
like I'll show you later after her date
it was [ __ ] up it's bad I was really
pissed if somebody told me that on the
street oh yeah no it's not good no it's
not good so he deleted it
because I'm a hundred percent of the
comments were like holy [ __ ] dude like
why did you post this this is my
favorite the top comment was too
old-timey on this one Jimmy you know
yeah he deleted it but the most recent
one isn't much better oh my God to a
girl and he said you got two tickets to
titsburg oh my God come on dude
Jimmy I can't you what happened he
pivoted to like sexual harassment yeah
what we can all do this at Pink's Hot
Dogs love pink oh my God I think Pink's
dropped him after that he actually just
posted on his story one of their feed
picks he just reposted it feed picks one
of their feedback about their store do
you wonder if he actually does it oh my
God
in like 15 seconds is amazing in this
yeah what I just told you guys just the
beginning it gets worse yeah yeah I'm
not gonna pull it up because I think we
got to ice him for a while we're having
fun yeah he you know but anyway
um
wait gift DPI is gifted 900 now all
right come on man come on man come on
out of control thank you so much another
50.50 who are you bro
uh V friends did a pop-up Cafe that's
all I'm seeing as of now no updates on
the restaurant did you need a v-friend
to get the food at the pop-up uh I'm not
exactly sure on that I was looking for
it but they did tease some v-front Uno
cards that are coming out
dude Uno cards that's fire yo he's
making Uno cards Kayla
that's so sick everybody's got at least
10 packs of Uno
my name is babak it's my 29th birthday
today and would love for to hear you try
to pronounce my name babak I mean it's
b-a-b-a-k
bye-bye
[Music]
happy birthday bud all right please God
damn Jay just gave 100 gifts to what the
you guys please a super troop wait what
is happening
it's the last show of the Year man
people people are hyped wait why does it
say
was gifted a membership by a hunt oh so
I see what's happening it's handing out
the defending amount yeah
dude I love this feature it it randomly
selects from people watching the most
active viewers that's really cool so
sick yeah
thank you guys did
yeah so people get notified like how do
they know that they got it yeah I think
something pops up on your screen uh and
it says you've just been gifted by this
person cute
yeah it doesn't work on certain
platforms though so if you've been
watching for a while and you're like why
am I not getting it and you like uh
does it work on mobile there's a feature
you have to turn on manually to allow to
like accept the gifted sub from people
yeah so just Google it I'm sure it's a
thousand now it's all sorted dude this
guy literally gifted a thousand Subs bro
how much money is that like five bucks a
pop right five okay five thousand
thousand dollars what bro 100 DPI that's
crazy you steal a credit card
it's not my business this transactions
between him and YouTube right like 5 000
God damn thank you so much that's
actually insane thank you Katie Mel
awesome all right let's let's do a show
here thank you guys
um Elon Musk is Banning journalists I
mean the guy's such a [ __ ] loser
I'm I know I know one thing I'm never
getting back on Twitter oh it's not
happening after all this but I I'm still
fairly confident in six months there
won't be a Twitter to come back to so so
um I wouldn't worry about it too much
real quick about an update on the pay
for Twitter
um we're able to change our name now
like that was locked yeah but they took
away my check mark when you when I
changed my name yeah what food and you
have to so you have to pay again no I'm
I I I'm still paying it I'm still paying
I'm still but I don't want the [ __ ]
check mark anymore
he'll get it back they have like a down
period to make sure it's not just Spam
it's been like two weeks oh
oh and they're still charging you yeah
those [ __ ] you're being scammed yeah
reality is [ __ ] service yeah so I don't
have my check mark but I was able to
change my name
so I guess I guess it's better but you
can change your name without the check
mark yeah yeah so you paid to be able to
change your name once yeah which you
could do before you could do before
shout out Twitter gotta love it yeah I
remember him saying hey it's just you're
paying for a different perspective right
right here you go there you go nailed it
thank you Butler sellers happy uh 2022
everybody love you too love you all man
love you all such a nice year we had
such a great year honestly if we're
gonna be retrospective a little bit um
are we are we gonna get emotional no we
haven't we have another show we might
want to do that next at the end yeah
because it's kind of it feels like a
final show of the Year kind of thing and
we're technically not there
but I do want to just say like it has
been very good a great year I feel like
it's been a formative year for the
podcast where I agree I love pizza and I
love people that's right actually you
know it's the most important ingredient
on the H3 podcast
the people
um
and then the pizza wow
I feel like the fans came together I
feel like our fandom our the fupa
Troopers are stronger tight-knit
Community I feel that we here in this
crew are working in Perfect Harmony we
have like this well-oiled machine
because nobody
nobody
Buzz It Like Us
[Applause]
podcast
are y'all crushing it man y'all are you
guys are all doing are so good
oh
[Applause]
important update yes Mr 100 DPI
it's the original members go up he just
messaged me Members go up yes it's our
original Saudi benefactor he's back okay
it's him he changed his name bad he
changed his name to 100 DPI he said he
didn't want to hijack the live show but
listen man I mean you are being so
generous you you considered the hijack
was that the Ukrainian dude yeah yeah
how the [ __ ] oh my God and it actually
came back he's dethroning himself with
this with the fresh account he says yo
bro this goes out to you brother yeah no
Vladimir
that guy sucks man
wow that's so cool
I want to cry yeah I'll get I'll get
more sappy during the live stream it
really has been such a phenomenal year
and I wake up every morning
excited I like the week I like the work
week you know I'm excited to come into
work which is maybe the first time in my
life
I mean I like this podcast but it's
gotten more as our team's gotten better
and um you all have taken more and more
off me
it's become a Joy
and something I look forward to instead
of something that's just like work you
know what I mean
so I thank you all
and the fans have been tremendous source
of support too it's just unbelievable
you know well thank you guys I think we
kind of all feel the same we love coming
into work
thanks bro anyone else want to say I
they appreciate that baby I'm sorry I
was talking to our benefactor um yeah no
we have a blast here it's it's a
privilege to work here and uh and yeah
you're right this is uh
when doing the sound bites uh putting
this together is kind of like an
interesting way to kind of remind
yourself retrospective because it comes
from all these things and uh
you know sometimes it feels like time
flies by but also this was a jam-packed
year man there's stuff that we did at
the beginning of this year that I'm like
how is that how is that this year so
right yes it's been a good one so thank
you everybody thank you everybody for
watching awesome and thank you guys you
know I want to thank everybody on the
crew really I think first of all Ian has
shine this year in his room absolutely I
mean he's he's the live switcher but
he's more than that he's kind of the
head
um the head writer he's spearheads are
sketches and planned segments and um
takes the lead on a lot of that stuff
and I feel that Ian really came into his
own this year I appreciate that thank
you that's very sweet thank you
I appreciate the uh opportunity to do it
um yeah you you Rose to the occasion you
really did it's cool when I moved here
like years and years ago that I I wanted
to do comedy stuff and it's like I'm
getting paid to like write comedy [ __ ]
and do that's like the dream you know
the dream is awesome yeah man you're
doing awesome honestly you're you're the
best at it now and I wouldn't even
[ __ ]
dude I'll tell you what if Ricky Gervais
came here looking for a job I'd kick him
in the [ __ ] balls
throw them out that's my British brother
so you're gonna all right I'll let you
get back I'll let you take a step back
um Zach of course is a maniac you guys
he's the best in the biz in fact I don't
think anyone even holds a light a candle
in his website thank you at this point I
am now agree I think yeah
he's too he's too humble to admit this
but I think he's surpassed the mentor at
this point really absolutely absolutely
are we talking about Fred dude I listen
to Howard Stern I will Zach is on Zach's
better
I'm glad you agree
Zach drops the bites before you even say
them out yeah he's like reading your
mind sometimes we listen to Howard
nowadays and we're like
Fred's kind of slow right your friend is
slipping he's slipping if you listen to
the older episodes yeah you gave me that
that like
listen he's an incredible feeling that
you give me Zach where he's like he sees
it coming he's hitting all these great
because that's where we really got the
idea to to build this kind of sound uh
role and uh me and Zach both being
children of uh Howard's Legacy yes yeah
but you're definitely um
you're the best in the biz I really I
really appreciate that I just want to
say I thank you guys thank you the fans
for everything
um four years I mean this is [ __ ]
amazing and you gave me an opportunity
to be a psycho with [ __ ] and like I can
I can make music for the show and like
it's truly a dream job so thank you guys
very much yeah you stepped up too it's
so cool I mean y'all been working here
for so long and
you guys Dan included I mean this job
has evolved so much since the five years
that we've been here I think Dan and Ian
were are the oldest ones yeah I've been
here like five years
yes that's crazy and Dan Dan the amount
that you're able to scale up is insane
because when you first started we were
literally had like one little sound
switch it was like so it was like a 75
uh Behringer mixer from Amazon and uh
and one computer and a couple cameras
and now look at us we still got the
mixer here in the back
yeah you got it that was our I think our
one piece of equipment
and it sounded like [ __ ] so it was
terrible and I insisted we get a better
one pretty much immediately
two audio racks like yeah baby we're
killing it now
yeah AB actually made a huge difference
for me when he joined
we took a we took a gamble hiring ab and
Lena we had a good feeling about them
yeah so but you guys moved out here from
Detroit
um
I basically reached down into the bowels
of the world and saved your life yeah
you really did you really know Lina was
quick with the years yep yep yeah
actually that's true 100 no I'm just I'm
just I'm just oh
[Music]
you guys jumped at the opportunity and
you both have well AB brings to the he
kind of
this show we were doing I think when you
started maybe like once or twice a week
yeah twice a week
[Music]
and uh with ab's help really we were
able to scale to the four episodes we do
now um oh yeah no way without a b yes he
he he's the head of preparing
the show the document the research so he
has brought
that stability and that four day a week
energy
that I didn't think or at least I wanted
to do it but I didn't know how we would
get there
Zach
I mean not Zach
a b brought us there
whoever you are yeah who's they be don't
worry I call I called like yeah you
didn't know who Sam was
one of those people
Lena transformed our life too yeah she's
our personal assistant or I mean
executive assistant let's be real it's
more than that
Ultra executive
Super Saiyan Super Saiyan executive
guardian angel
like the most reliable person ever Nanny
when we need like she can do it all she
got Bruce to take a nap yesterday that's
on the couch not in our hands I come to
back to the living room it's quiet I'm
like where's the Bruce he was on the
couch taking a nap I'm like how did you
do it I didn't even hear any noise yeah
that's crazy that is crazy but really
thank you guys so much for everything I
know I say it all the time but you
literally changed our lives I mean we
always wanted to move out to LA and then
just having it happen this way like when
we found out we got the jobs I was
crying I'll never forget that feeling so
yeah just think so much I'll never
forget the day you came to the office do
you remember the first day and they may
go there yeah I do I remember that day I
remember Lena calling me after like
nearly in tears Gila is the nicest
person I've ever met
I still remember because I was like
super super nervous but then after like
actually meeting you I'm like oh like
you're just so cool and casual and it
was kind of weird for me to be shy so I
felt comfortable immediately yeah I
remember you said something like I was
super nervous but I feel I feel less
nervous now as I'm feeling that
that was the old office that's how long
ago that [ __ ] was I forgot that you guys
started yeah we were in our tiny little
dentist office I don't want to hog up
all the time I just want to say we
really do appreciate you guys and uh we
told you when we started we'd work hard
and I felt like we were we weren't
qualified at least me no one here is
qualified yeah I hope
that's the magic starting with us yeah
but I appreciate everyone being patient
with me everyone helping and being there
for me especially beginning and I love
you guys thank you there it is and now
you're promoting pictures of you and
idubbbz on Instagram yeah
didn't get my KFC yet though I'm still
waiting yeah
let's not come I'm fighting for my life
together
I need to be promoted in order for them
to save me
thank you guys yes Sam by the way Sam
also is like the prop Master genius
who's Sam I've seen some of the stuff
you're working for uh the live show for
Craigslist and I was like oh man nobody
could do this I have created my best
work is it the one that I saw yeah
I just finished it today I truly think
it's my best work it is so freaking
funny and good I I don't know what I
would do without her here because like
that thing
I'm like hey can you make this happen
she's like yeah I got it and it pulls it
off and that thing is insane I saw you
tinkering like in the corner with what
looked like dental floss and a fan and I
was like what the hell is going on
everyone keeps walking by asking me what
I'm doing and I'm like
you'll see it but it's very hard to
explain yeah I feel like with our with
everyone here we can literally do
anything any idea we have as crazy as it
is we get it done we do it that's the
magic you know what I mean that's what I
love about it cam has been on fire by
the way and Cam's a big part of that
right how much we can do with like the
backgrounds and the set the virtual sets
right and the memes during the show uh
the editing cam does all that and he
brings he's so good at what he's what
his job is and he's so fast and I think
him being here
is a really important factor as well oh
yeah and us being able to basically do
whatever it is that we want having that
magic back here dude thank you very much
I can't I mean echoing everybody else
here I can't thank you guys enough you
saved me from a boring estate job when I
got here and now you can gamble on the
lottery yeah now I can gamble on the
lottery again I'm gonna win big tonight
actually and the Mega Millions oh yeah
is it a big one uh for over 400 million
gonna win I'm gonna win it all right
good luck buddy I just want to say this
is Cam and Maya's formal resignation we
are winning the lottery tonight exactly
yeah I'm gonna win and I'll give Zach
Thomas you gotta win before you resign
dude yep I'm gonna well I'm gonna win
don't worry but yeah this year [ __ ]
ruled I turned in uh from a bunny to a
human being yes who knows I thought it
was that away next year but uh
yeah thank you guys so much it is a
blessing to come into work every day and
laugh so
yeah you're awesome dude thank you I
also want to say thank you guys so much
because if I could like design my dream
job it would be what I'm doing and I
think it's insane that I get to come in
and do the insane things that I do and
now I've made a living primarily
portraits it's really awesome right
torture but also we got some to to help
us with Teddy freshman it's been so fun
and and now I feel like we have that
super power on Teddy fresh too where
before I felt like we were kind of
missing like a glue to to bring our team
together when it came to like the
marketing side of it and now it's like
we can have random ideas and Sim is
there to make it happen and it's really
cool
thank you yeah it's awesome
and of course Olivia's the queen of slay
she brings the sleigh pills
because we didn't have slave pills
before definitely not now we do some
days I feel I'm overdosing on slate
happy to provide
personally you know you were giving me a
lot of credit for all the shows it was
really you know as we started to ramp up
I started a little scared and I had
everyone of course help me out but
Olivia has been such a great help I
can't say it enough I have a great lion
for Olivia so hello thank you for all
the help yeah Olivia supports a B on
research and prepping and obviously she
has a unique uh Talent set
of the sleigh perspective it's happening
and the youth
it's happening every single day I walk
in I feel honored to be here good sweets
by the way too oh thank you so much I'm
glad that you're still seeing them I do
still see them I don't know why but they
show up on my food but thank you guys so
much I can never express how grateful I
am
thank you say it again Jen say it again
and love is our Swedish meatball out
there he's working behind the scenes
he's working behind the scenes but uh we
love it we love his uh Special Blend of
flavors and meat lean and fat Meats
combined to make a nice little Swedish
meatball
thank you thank you appreciate that but
we're gonna get out here
and yeah I'm gonna take your passport
and make you a human slave but that's
fine that's great well I'm sure you want
I'm very thankful as well of course this
has literally changed my life so much
um
I'm also under qualified I don't even
have any University or college or
anything I'm straight out of uh what's
it called High School right straight up
yeah streets yep yeah
and I was working this shitty job before
or a while you guys asked me to join the
crew and I quit that [ __ ] in two weeks
and I started working uh with you guys
that was great I was playing five bucks
an hour you're making fun you can get
paid five bucks an hour in Sweden yeah
there's no minimum wage in Sweden I know
minimum oh [ __ ] I was like working
myself into the ground dude
oh my God yeah I was like working like
14 hours a day because I knew I was I
was under qualified for that job too I
took a risk I took that job I kind of
made a deal with the boss I'm like can I
work here but you don't have to pay me
that much because I don't have any
education and I'm like because I thought
that would be my step into a career
without School wait what was it I kind
of just it's like web development SEO
advertising and all that [ __ ] so I did
so much that's smart though actually
that was a smart man yeah I did not want
to go back to school basically yeah so
yeah I lived at home so I lived at home
so I
it wasn't that bad boy well um y'all are
the best at what you do so it's kind of
amazing we're like the ragtag crew
what's the ragtag crew there's like
superhero brag tag
yeah so there that's what it is you know
when love started the Pod we were at 35
000 on Insta right yeah and now we're at
235 wow I mean tacos grown a lot 700k
this week actually yeah we might be
hitting a million on Tick Tock
love can you do anything about our
podcast Subs going down
I've been trying yeah I don't know I
know the tick tock game pretty well yeah
yeah we're about we're about to hit next
year 2.8 million Subs on the podcast so
that's exciting finally our sub number
is actually just a countdown to the end
of the pod that's right and there's
nobody left guys
you're the last one
somebody says don't discount yourself
love you are loved what why
people don't believe me I'll I'll tell
you guys a little bit I was worried
about you I was paid
per month
and I worked overtime but I wasn't paid
for the overtime so my hourly rate went
down basically that's hard I thought it
I thought they had better labor laws in
Sweden it sounds like you got you pretty
good no yeah I mean that was definitely
not very not legal yeah yeah okay shut
up all right you got to come up you came
I had to juice I learned a lot I learned
a lot during our job so I'm not
complaining that much actually yeah
well there it all is uh anyway I don't
know how we got here but Elon Musk is a
giant piece of [ __ ] okay uh two things
one uh I didn't want to interrupt that
love Fest
um but we are definitely at our break
time so let's thank our favorite
e-commerce website real fast here Adam
and Eve
adamandeve.com they sell tubes
and socks that you put tubes in and also
lubricants
that you would use on perhaps
well Luke whatever needs tubing
lubricants are used to
the pieces can glide easier on
mechanical parts
like WD-40 but
but more organic I guess you could say
organic material right right right right
right and you know
um let me just tell you right off the
bat yeah
tight ring fits
it's a good point you can get a ring
well you know most people they get rings
on their hands or their feet some people
do feet Rings sure but some people get
rings somewhere else and that's part of
the e-commerce experience that they
offer sure
also right off the bat I just want to
tell you guys at adamandeve.com you will
get 50 off almost any item plus free
shipping
that is flipping insane
use code after dark at checkout to get
the offer
that is 50 off almost any item plus free
shipping the link is in the description
but yeah one of their my favorite
e-commerce is the beauty and Body Care
uh section of adamandeve.com nice
e-commerce there
um any other e-commerce categories bath
and body bath and body shaving cream
yeah shaving cream
yeah so go there for that but also shop
around because they've got a ton of
other stuff that you are going to love
yeah you'd be very interested in some of
the others they've got it all frankly
and for 50 off you can't lose it's Adam
and Eve it's a great deal adamandeve.com
the world's favorite e-commerce website
yeah we love them love them yes
[Music]
oh okay
yeah I don't know if I should even
bother with the Elon Musk or just
straight into the tournament I'm kind of
thinking like it's such a downer yeah he
says a weirdo [ __ ] we got a lot to do
the guy he just lost his mind he's
literally Banning journalists for being
meanies to him so stupid yeah also while
we're doing the appreciation oh yeah
there's something about so I had
mentioned that Ian's five has been here
five years yeah his anniversary was
actually recently it was last week last
week Ian was here for five years
officially at the podcast
so we like to honor people are running
people are running yeah I see that
people are running here in the office
they all left in the studio the whole
crew has left we're out
all right see you dude anyway thanks for
the five years yeah so you know five
years is a long time for any job yeah
that's basically the whole run so Ian
Ian who started as in the intern that
had no face right became in the salaried
employee and which didn't have a face
and now is uh what would you call here
now he's Ian the manager the manager
Ian the executives are our last live
show I was working the merch Booth right
and no one knew who I was like maybe a
big idea yeah yeah not long ago because
we never showed him there was maybe
three people that were like your voice
is familiar are you Ian I'm like yeah
whoa that's so crazy that's so funny
they know you now okay well I guess I'll
open this here yeah so we got you a
little present it was kind of hard to
decide but what we got you is um
we want you to enjoy yourself over the
break or whenever you want you know take
a little trip
we got you a uh
uh enough to make a round-trip flight
anywhere in the United States yeah
pretty much so the the thought because
we we've noticed what you've been
talking about that you've always wanted
to go to the Big Apple New York City the
Greatest Town in the world but you've
never been to New York
and he's always wanted to go I won't
show this just in case it says
uh to Delta for flight 50
750. I was like what the [ __ ] did we buy
you 750 yeah yeah go to New York you'll
be joining uh Jimmy Lee in Jersey so
yeah you can meet up with your boy
thank you guys so much this is amazing
yeah of course thank you and uh well
deserved thank you everyone take some
time off this is great yeah I bet you uh
did you just leave that right on right
on the computer yeah and unfortunately
the shark is there we didn't have any
gift cards so we were gonna get that
yeah that was the original we fell back
on the plane tickets oh my God wow oh
for old time's sake here we go
wow
[Music]
[Music]
yes thank you half a decade that's so
crazy yeah it's a long time we in time
long time you know what I mean
five years haven't aged a day over five
days definitely not sailing well you
know um you look better than ever you
did thank you everyone looks great thank
you but you know I've never looked good
and that has never looked good
you have never looked good but
um you know
Howard Stern all those guys have been
together for like 40 years so
35 years left Ian let's see what we got
to go let's see you you know you never
know
but uh yeah so you can eat that cake or
yeah
during the show I was gonna cut it do
you guys want some oops not um I'd
rather eat pizza can I order that now if
you're cutting the cake I'll have a
piece on me don't get me wrong should I
order pizza now yeah probably okay whoa
whoa whoa wait do you guys sure want
pizza or maybe Angel decide he's the
it's his big day oh chicken I feel like
we need Sharkies dude no
it's been a minute it's been a minute
you for real right now wait didn't you
res yeah maybe it was again who recently
said he tried turkeys again Ian loves
Sharkies I used to I go all the time
okay we went through a Sharky's phase
where we ate it every night for dinner
for like five days and then we swore it
off forever
yeah I'd say I'm gonna say I'm gonna be
a little responsible here if we're gonna
eat it should be in about two hours
towards the tail end of the show just to
avoid some smacking some shoes
he's become Ian the executive manager
and you guys are seeing it right in
front of you right now just thinking but
I'm hot out of the show five years of
chewing into the mic okay I'll listen
you know what you're talking about pizza
sounds good though I'm down for pizza
okay
yeah so um also did you guys want to
look at the streamer yells at chatter
for mom dying because I mentioned it
this club's [ __ ] nuts dude I made a
joke about it so you guys know what I
was talking about this girl who sadly
said I'm so sorry to hear it that her
brother had passed so this guy who's a
streamer I don't know if he's a big
streamer no no he's not but he has fans
yeah he is a little fan base so check
this out this is the craziest thing I've
ever seen on Twitch probably
um I'll just play it
just in Spanish and it's chef's kiss all
right
curvy where the [ __ ] have you been
oh my god well tell you what Miss dirty
Kirby you know what we're not gonna do
We're not gonna talk about it in my chat
because it's Friday and that is a hole
wait didn't you show the comment it was
there was a continue to skip over that
she replied with I'm sorry I've been
gone my mom just passed away and I've
been dealing with a lot wait where is it
in the was it cut out of here
oh yeah it must have been cut out of
this just in Spanish and it's chef's
kiss all right well he asked her where
have you been okay and she said I'm
sorry I mean where the [ __ ] have you
been yeah I don't know why what happened
it got cut out here
but she said sorry my mom passed away
and I've been dealing with a lot and
this is his response after he asked her
well tell you what Miss dirty Kerber you
know what we're not gonna do We're not
gonna talk about it in my chat
because it's Friday and that is today
baby big bucket of bummer oh my God I
lost but we're not doing that in my
[ __ ] chat what uh thank you well okay
Mr Kirby you said no that's fine you
asked so I told no I didn't ask you to
tell me the biggest [ __ ] bummer news
in the world I said hey what's up how
are you you know what let me give you a
little bit of a lesson especially when I
it's there's there's he's right you know
there's an assumption that when you ask
someone where have you been no bombers
no bombers only good news bro oh my god
dude this guy's kind of a reaction is
that I know it's just it's shocking man
y'all tell me all about your dead
relatives you drop it in the chat we're
gonna have
a dead homie moment here in chat I'm
sorry
we do Friday different drop all your
dead homies in chat oh
oh I work at I work at Adam and Eve uh
Adan says you pack the merchandise hell
yeah dude oh wow
oh she they say all sorts of merchandise
he says it's a good job and they got a
raise and a Christmas bonus that's
awesome
yeah congrats
yeah so here is the uh
this dude hates dead people Kirby when
something really really bad is going on
in your life and in a public forum
someone asked you hey what's up how are
you there are two acceptable response uh
responses good and you know what I'll
make it through that's what kind of wait
that's not a problem I'll it's okay I'll
make it through what the hell does that
mean you're one of your parents passed
away and you're gonna say okay I'll make
it through I'll be fine you know you I
you live that's the my favorite part is
he literally asked her where Have You
Been by name so he like knows this
person yeah who is a fan of his small
stream
oh yeah Rest in Peace by the way to all
the dead homies and family members in
chat this you know we do memorials here
every Friday
uh for our fallen because
um
we carry the ones we love with us
you know
so yeah I'm a good guy not unlike this
guy it's basically my point
that's it
how are you good or you know what I'll
make it through by the way I love hit
this psycho he goes if somebody tells
you I'll make it through and you don't
ask a follow-up right
he's like how are you they're like
you know I'll make it through he's like
okay cool well anyway
another alternative that he gives or
someone in chat gives and then he reads
it out loud is another response could
have been I'm alive which is literally
so crazy because her mother is not she's
not like oh my God I'm telling you
something yeah tap dance on your mom's
grade actually the inverse of that is
what she's trying to tell you but wow
wow this guy is wild for this is one of
the craziest takes ever man it's a hell
of a way to build a fan base approach
Derek says his father-in-law passed away
three years ago today and his
mother-in-law and Grandma both passed
this year
and his mom's been dead for over a
decade so I mean
the grace killed all 10 of my fathers
Rory said
that's the moral guy that's the mole guy
yeah Derek I'm sorry for your loss it's
never easy but uh
you know
just don't [ __ ] tell me about it who
actually I'll make it through is
probably a better thing
just kidding sorry for your loss Derek
Derek's a legend yeah I recognize that
name they they come around a lot right
yeah and they support like me and love
and lean on oh right on shout out Derek
yeah but I'm just saying dude I asked
for one dead family member you brand
like five don't bum me out dude
it's a little pick me it's a little pick
me with yeah oh oh oh you have how many
dead family members I get it
there you go bronze response I said prom
how are you doing she says I'm alive
by the way this poor girl is defending
herself she goes I'm not trying to bum
anyone out you asked me where I was so I
said where
it's so scared
to be the bearer of bad news was he
trying to be funny and this just like
he's thinking that he's funny but like
At first I said this guy's doing shtick
but then he keeps going with it and he
actually seems mad
he put out uh apology where he said this
person is coming his chat before and
Trauma dumped but I think obviously he's
just from a dumb shut up idiot you're
trauma dumping like me right now with
your childhood problems you also don't
have to read it like it's a chat you
don't have to right if you don't feel
like it just you know what I mean that's
true in his apology he says that she had
written it twice and he didn't
acknowledge it and then on the third one
he did that just muted it's not recorded
so there's I haven't seen evidence of
that but oh God but that is what he says
I'll I'll watch the apology because I'm
actually super interested in this um
this Arc here
oh I asked you where you were look Mr
Kirby
all I'm trying I'm just subtly trying to
tell you that unloading really heavy
news in people's Chats on Twitter yeah
he's like listen I'm trying to subtly
tell you that I'm glad she's dead
that's how much I care by the way this
guy's a Class Act is a tower of empty
beer cans behind him
you know he's well adjusted which is not
like good etiquette it's just it's not
gonna talk about etiquette that's all
what you're you're like yelling at
somebody that just had their parent die
and you're talking about etiquette I
mean this guy's like five fans and she's
one of them you're being so rude like
are you even gonna say the word
etiquette he's just say listen
somebody's got to teach her what I'm
trying to tell you
that's it I'm just I figured this is a
good opportunity to inform you
heavy news like that when someone asks
hey where have you been
no my dog there's no like um sardine
paste
what's the red it is in here I know I
could be a non-flashback whenever same
hands me food I know I don't think
that's right
happy 42nd Ethan hey
surprise all right my birthday's in June
first of all so the joke doesn't even
work on its face
joke
pounder says your birthday is today wait
this I thought we were doing this yeah
no the calendar wait
yeah this is for today yeah December
16th there it is it says on the calendar
right here what calendar are you looking
at the official this is the official I'm
37. is this cake for me or Ian then
you tell me Dan it was a joint thing
yeah we figured because it overlapped we
didn't want to do two parties it's a
tall cake it's wine on top of the other
right right two people
what the [ __ ] you
by the way Eva happy birthday happy uh
32nd birthday this week oh yeah don't do
that don't do that it was also Sam's
birthday too so happy birthday Sam Sam
just turned uh 14.
14. everyone else that's not even funny
oh I'm sorry
man I'm so sorry let's talk about Ian
for a minute Howell yo Ian you're in
trouble
Ian be like I just met this high school
girl
what was on the agenda tonight
just for the right
thank you
uh back to this Ada husband left me for
a younger woman my house burnt down and
my car got stolen so I've been a little
bit busy that's why I haven't been
around because it's like oh this guy's
actually so dumb he's this is great like
what he just said is my dream comment I
get them on the phone immediately you
know what I mean like you just don't
even know if I'm under your nose
God like oh
oh like you know like if this guy's the
worst friend to have in the whole world
this is what he thinks to himself
anytime a friend or family tells him bad
news your house burned oh [ __ ] dude
seriously can we not talk about it it's
Friday bro let's just play Smash Dude I
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah
where have you been and it's heavy like
yo can I stay with you until my
until I find a new place bro there's a
homeless shelter down the street
I don't want to hear it I
got it
that's it
I'm not trying to rip you a new ass
oh you're not I love that little laugh
biggest cell phone maybe ever although
keemstar is pretty
close on those butt yeah you made an
apology which I haven't seen yet
because this guy was getting
that clip was going around Twitter yeah
he first apologized on Twitter and then
he put out a video
let's see
after the first message she followed up
simply by carefullying
it's it's down here the apology so oh so
she posted it to Twitter she got her
revenge on this model I posted the link
and that's how people let's go Miss
nerdy curvy got your ass punk
so she put out a statement
which I'm not going to read
but uh sure it's I mean you know I mean
it's okay it's a trauma dump and it's
Friday and it would be kind of a bummer
to read it so I mean he should read it
right
it's none of my business
I'm just here to roast that guy
it's a pretty long post when's this girl
Gonna Learn her lesson man
it's Friday dude
goes this is a pretty epic response uh
you've seen the edits but what it
doesn't show is that twice I didn't
acknowledge her comments about the
deceased family member on purpose I read
them to myself but didn't react and
didn't know this makes sense he's
totally off the hook you guys didn't see
that she was saying it three times
and I ignored her one of my five fans
was trying to bond with me I continually
ignored her you guys didn't miss you
that part where I was even more of a
dead in depth
to call out a lot of the context and
dialogue required I feel
to fairly assess the matter as it truly
unfolded
uh you've seen the edits but what it
doesn't show is that twice I didn't
acknowledge her comments about the
deceased family member on purpose
I read them to myself but didn't react
in depth
like this is so heavy and then he's like
that's a bad word that's success at her
yeah it just doesn't go together by the
way that's a good Sound by Zach
you got it
what is this shine behind him that is
the name of his channel it's we found
the body which one could argue is the
absolute worst news in the entire world
right he doesn't tolerate heavy news but
that's the name of his entire he found
the body that is the worst thing news
you could hear
right there
hold on a b say that again so that's the
smallest sign I've ever seen for a
channel I don't know how much
advertising is
that's true it is small but it's legible
temporarily hijacked uh by this type of
heavy serious trauma commenting it
wasn't until the third time that she
brought it up in chat and expressed how
horrible life has been that I reacted to
it the way that I did one very important
detail that I think I should share is
that this individual has been spoken to
about
has been spoken to about this uh before
dude you're a [ __ ] monster sorry why
he's not even willing to apologize the
thing is the thing is she's had a lot of
terrible things happened yeah
so it's really annoying it's not just
like a one-time annoyance but like
her life is in shambles like he already
yelled at her and yeah like that's
annoying bro sorry this cake is so good
I'm gonna wrap it up
probably where's that strawberry jam
it's really good
Strawberry Shortcake
[ __ ] it it's my birthday
[Applause]
let's [ __ ] go 42 years young and I
feel great yeah as soon as you said that
you look younger to me yeah
you look not a day over 37 my friend
yeah you know four-year-old man a 34
year old man
wow that's one voiceover in a while
and he's complimenting 34. you're 34
dude
thanks bro
um
yeah you know sometimes people having a
hard time apologizing which I get
I've been through that myself I feel
I've gotten better at apologizing over
the years
there's a certain bit you just have to
kind of swallow your pride
and
learn you just got to be able to really
say I did [ __ ] up you're right like
that's hard to say right like you're
right I'm wrong sorry
okay Dan it's not now's another time
try to make a point
uh but this guy can't even on the I
yelled at a girl for her dad dying
couldn't make the [ __ ] apology
there it is
he's basically trying to get people
upset at her yeah
isn't she annoying yeah
that's the apology video yeah you guys
don't understand she's really [ __ ]
annoying yeah the context that you guys
missed which I think would have made a
difference is what a dumb [ __ ]
oh crazy so that was kind of a fun but
let you know what I think it's time is
it we interviewed yeah our competitors
let's [ __ ] go on the 20 22 sound bite
World Olympics go
no stinger
little stinger
here it is it's dramatically Rising
actually I need to pee so uh not to be
anticlimactic like seriously I do need
to pee
that's the Stinger we got a stinger for
your bathroom bro can we do it at the
same time you want to go together we
take turns let's go pee and then we're
gonna come back go knock it out it'll be
faster if you both go at the same time
yeah but don't talk about any of these I
won't say a word the troubadour
yes thank you Ela January 6th
Insurrection
with Zach Lewis everyone actually you
moved it to the Capitol oh it's in DC
now yes hell yeah happy anniversary in
the capital rotunda yeah no but
seriously January 13th it's coming up
I'm so excited
um it's sold out it's been sold out for
a while but it's gonna be so much fun
and uh look forward to seeing everyone
there it sold out so long ago second day
yeah second shot well uh I guess I'll
announce this we I'm gonna be playing at
the Roxy let's go [ __ ] go dude yes
um that is sometime in May still finding
out the specifics of that but it's gonna
be at the Roxy the Roxy's legendary
venue here in Los Angeles on the Sunset
Strip the famous Sunset Strip many many
very famous bands uh came up
you know who I saw at the Roxy in 2012
or 11 Ariana Grande when she's still on
Victorious I saw James Charles there
really I also so from that Roxy show I
actually found out some other exciting
news there's no promises but it the
chances are highly likely because I saw
another Troubadour and if I saw the Roxy
there's a very high chance I might be
playing at Coachella
yeah that's not real no that's actually
real tonight
I'm gonna win 400 million too Zach you
don't believe me no actually he's like
in uh Kanye's spot yeah I'm just kidding
I mean you seem pretty serious so maybe
a little bit of me well because maybe
you're not [ __ ] around but no
seriously because uh the Roxy is owned
by um golden voice and they like to see
Trends so it's not a definitive thing
but it could be possible I'm manifesting
it for you dude all right thank you Sam
I choose to believe everybody all in the
audience right now put out some thought
positive thought vibrations yes exactly
thank you Coachella every day every day
I look in the mirror are you no no
trauma no no bombers dude we're all
positivity Positive Vibes we're
manifesting right now
Zach Coachella yes it would be 21 it
would be 2024 though it wouldn't be this
year it'd be the phone okay fix your
positive manifestation thoughts
everybody to 2024 not 25.
correction in the universe cam uh Cody
McFarland just donated 10 Australian
dollars and asked Dan Kemp how was covet
it was great I got to go backstage
before the show I'm kind of buddies with
Yvette and uh it was great oh yeah yeah
I was uh I was not really familiar with
them but I I like that kind of music and
cam had an extra ticket invited me and I
scoped them out online and was like this
seems pretty cool so I went along and I
had a great time I thought they rocked
so uh yeah check out covet everyone yeah
thank you very much for coming Dan you
got it thanks for inviting me all right
let's pretend that uh we didn't go to
the bathroom and let's just go back to
the top yeah exactly guys introducing
the 2022 World sound bite Champions this
is it it's all come down to these 32
incredible competitors
I may I say the competition has never
been fiercer we had so many Fantastic
entries in fact
that we couldn't even fit them all in
one in one bracket so we had to really
come together
and narrow it down
to the top 35 and maybe we have before
we should do our honorable mentions
before we get into that to pay homage to
the great sound bites that didn't make
the cut but who really needs to be
acknowledged for their excellence
is that in vmix or do I I believe it is
so let's go ahead first and pay it pay
homage
to our honorable sound bites
hell yes
it's 14 pages
it's me why did you unmatch me
who's Sam
what are you afraid of Ian who wants me
to take their money who wants to lose
some money today let's not talk about
making money
knock it over my wife thank you
exploding Milk porn
Jamie Gooch Gooch Gooch Family Farms
Gooch advises Moms while Gucci's opinion
may not be the most fun
get your balls off my face man what is
wrong with you [ __ ] you fake Call Me
ass grifter dog [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
jacket off
oh my God like can we talk about like
the political and economic state of the
world right now
I prefer really not to not to speak if I
speak I am in in big trouble
I'm not gay no more
I'm really good
gotta have them ribs and [ __ ] too
real funny
rip a dart I'm just spitting facts you
know yeah I know yeah 21 21 Savage is
basically like my spirit animal and [ __ ]
[Music]
get your [ __ ] ass up and work work it
seems like nobody wants to work these
days
[Music]
money money
give to you
stick your finger
oh
coming out now
yeah as you can see
that even in the honorable category
they're all so strong they are and just
an incredible feat so I love seeing that
over
uh it was hard it was hard to let some
of those go the Ben Affleck one it's me
I love
but enough of them
yes let's get on to our finalists this
is the world championship so let's start
from the top shall we yeah yeah this one
changed
the world
this has defined the year
um just real quick
should I put up the poll immediately
when we get to the category or should we
wait to go over them and then pull what
do you think go over them okay because
that's gonna slow things down quite a
bit no but they need one they need the
full content okay fair enough so I'll
just have the pollen stand by him
although you would get more people
voting yeah maybe put it up I think
maybe yeah yeah it'll keep things moving
a lot faster too so we have
how we prolapse
verse
Steve will do it Donnie time drops now
some of these are going to come in a
package because there's there's like you
know five different sound bites right
the Donnie one that we like so we're
gonna pack gym up okay
now the how we won again this is Howie's
year this man took the World by storm he
took took duck by a storm can I show
this this is like we're not blurred
enough you guys
yeah give me the one with the rose butt
okay
yeah here's my friend Neil bent over
this happened does somebody know is this
covet related and if it is what do we do
about it
ow this one has
isn't just a great sound drop it has
cultural significance yes you know
um it changed everything yeah it changed
EU there's pretty Howie and post Howie
yeah that's a big deal and I want to
affect things too much
but
I want to say
Howie is my favorite to win not even
necessarily my favorite but it's the one
that I like if we're betting I would say
I think this is going yeah you could say
you can say that I mean there's
definitely going to be favorites in here
we just want to give the full context I
have some article titles about how he's
Tick-Tock real quick it's uh Howie
Mandel claims he did not know what it
was Holly Mandel's prolapse video shocks
the internet leaves it traumatized oh
yeah uh Howie Mandel's Tick Tock is the
grossest place on the internet those are
three article titles yeah he he really
he changed the world
it
really was it really was
I the thing is you got the voting open
now and I feel like nobody's gonna vote
for Donnie if they haven't heard the
sound bite yet
yeah I think I don't think I think close
it close it lock it up and redo it we
gotta redo it yeah we gotta redo it it's
just we have to be
okay you know what I mean and I I listen
I think how he's gonna win but I want to
give Steve who's my best friend Donnie
it would be nice if you could have it
but not yet ready like you can't vote
yet I don't think they have that option
do they where you like you open it for
both
once we've no but I I I'll have it typed
up so like it's right and we don't have
to wait yeah you know but yeah
so again this was a really culturally
significant moment and this is kind of
what
I'm afraid of in these tournaments were
two Titans and me right in an early
round it's really hard and again this
one rocked me to the core I showed it to
a lot of guests and it even culminated
in a beautiful friendship between me
Bradley and Steve will do it and even
Kyle who rips starts like a [ __ ]
monster like nobody nobody shout the
[ __ ] out yeah no yeah people sends those
darts right into his lunch so like 2023
is going to be the year of Ethan and now
the year you know so so
all that being said
here it is yes so lately I've been just
like row so you just go you put on the
glove and he said Donald you should go
on the stomach or like on his number
right here or like you go cow style cow
stuff this is cow Styles what do you
talk better for catching and then you go
and usually just play like uh like uh
like I like cartoon like Disney like
family friendly and [ __ ] uh and you just
has been uh I've been just like jerking
off Donnie jerking your dog off I swear
wait wait wait wait wait hold on so
you're telling me right now that you've
been jerking yourself
not this it might sound crazy but it's
Strictly Business uh okay
it's very and kind of I watch something
occupy myself and it's more of just a
it's more of a little workout but the
thing is like dude I'm the cool dad
because imagine if you couldn't jerk off
and now he says
um that it was a joke that they planned
ahead of time of course the poll we took
on that day
the audience disagrees by a lot the
audience was so [ __ ] up for that poll
I'm still so upset about that yeah it
was 90 with like 50 000 votes said right
they believe Steve did do it but take it
from me I have the Intel I'm friends
with these guys it was a joke they
planted ahead of time no the audience
would be in a couple of half centers
yeah Mage or half centers out there all
right so let's throw it up we have Howie
prolapse
what do we do about it when my friend
Neil bent over this happened does
somebody know is this covid related
and if it is
what do we do what do we do about it
that one I mean what do we do about it
alone as
yeah so much power
and then even just the owl became ow but
then if you Zach if you go over to the
Steve will do it Legacy have sex with
Donnie yeah I'm the cool dad now
or like you go cow Style
Donnie Donnie yeah that one gets a lot
of play Donnie
all right yeah I mean listen 5 000
people voted we can already wrap it up
and there's no surprises but I did want
to give it a fair shake that um yeah
Howie's gonna win with 75 which let's be
honest that's not a total blowout for
sure like as far as a first round up
against Howie I think Steve had he did
admirably he did a good show yeah I took
it down okay yeah and well it's too late
Howie even nothing the damage is done
and we will never forget ow
All Right Moving On
second bracket congratulations Howie
Mandel congratulations round two
here we go our very own Ryan Cavanaugh
of course the uh
the uh oh wow profoundly
um
incompetent Ryan Kavanaugh and that is
Ryan Cavanaugh is a force of nature who
has you know run
a relativity media into bankruptcy a
production company that was so big
people thought it wasn't even possible
he did that now the owner of triller
also
a guy who says the craziest [ __ ] like
that you should never say publicly here
for example
thank you
um I was told if I came here that it was
Luke bassan who was introducing me and I
get to Star and lay professional too and
have an inappropriate relationship with
a 40 year old Natalie Portman so that's
the only reason I came I'm just joking
um
wait I think there's even there's even
more
first of all
too much wine sorry okay
wow still painful even after all the
times we've heard it and again with the
context of him
like emailing Natalie Portman and her
telling him to stop yelling me
it gets weird
but there it is Ryan Kavanaugh everyone
uh maybe not everyone but there are a
lot of chatters that are saying the poll
was not up long enough I really
it wasn't gonna it was statistically
significant I mean how are you gonna I
mean I gotta feel that way too but are
you gonna beat house no don't do it
again trust me it's fine guys I wouldn't
have called it if I didn't think it was
over it was 75 after 5 000 it was it was
over it was done people if it's closer
it won't live it up longer yeah yeah
yeah of course I'm trying not to pull
dude these these tournaments go for a
long time so yeah
all right so there's Ryan Cavanaugh uh
who is who
wants to have an inappropriate
relationship with a 14 year old Natalie
Portman too much wine sorry uh that
don't explain that you know what I mean
the wine but then you come to fresh and
fresh they want to say this is kind of a
battle a battle of the villains
Ryan Kavanaugh up against fresh and fit
it is Wednesday man it is
[Music]
wait this isn't our channel is it a
Street podcast soundbite no so we uh
when we're putting this together there
was a channel that went through and
found the origins of the sound bite so
shout out to uh to them that's awesome
yeah that's so cool
yeah so here it is I'm gonna say we want
to say if if people want to be like oh
my God you got the massage I said toxic
okay go suck a dick we don't give a [ __ ]
so uh let's pull up this clip right here
man this is how to say it sucks
someone's dick
oh reacted to us on an old video where
we're talking about using Instagram as a
girl is cheating okay and and uh Chris
you uh yeah I'm at it again it's okay
you got it for us yeah man it is
Wednesday shout out to our guy agent
yeah
it's funny it's still funny so funny
man it is Wednesday man it is Wednesday
man it is Wednesday bro what the [ __ ]
happened Wednesday like what happened
bro just to say that you got it for us
yeah man it is Wednesday shots our guy
agent yeah
not just to say
um speaking on the sound but it's one of
the sunlights I have on the quick
trigger because it's so versatile I feel
and use it a lot so that does say
something yeah you've got that on on
quick dial yeah exactly it is Wednesday
all right did I throw up the pole seen
both well no we haven't seen coconuts in
Barbados because fresh and fit comes in
a package deal
so then the other one and this is all
about the fresh
is uh we realized a great thinker what's
that Wednesday came out
and then we started to notice other oh
my God it looks so much fatter here
right yeah yeah
whoa okay
let's go
that's good to see whoa Jesus okay all
right take it easy
so here's coconuts and Barbados another
great Moment by it uh fresh so
yeah that's a whole other discussion
picking coconuts in Barbados yeah what's
your thoughts as far as like we will not
go oh yes Michaela did we find this by
accident in the Michaela Peterson one
thing yeah yeah I think we just came
across it I think I was showing it to
Dan and Dan was like wait what did he
just say dude what's the context on that
and I was like oh there is no contact
that's awesome yeah that's great that's
a home that is a home discovered sound
fight wow literally like he hasn't
looked at her still
yeah that's a whole other discussion
picking coconuts in Barbados yeah I mean
what's your thoughts yeah he pretend
like you hear that [ __ ] yeah whatever
okay that's what the [ __ ] he meant by
that
uh it is Wednesday man cooking cooking
picking up some Barbados he's right he's
full of fresh ideas yeah so here it is
we have got fresh really just fresh I'm
throwing up the pool it's fresh versus
Ryan Kavanaugh wanting to have an
inappropriate relationship
for the 14 year old Nanny Apartment A
mashup
of great minds and prolific business I
wonder if this one's going to be close
too much I have a feeling it won't be
yeah
yeah I have a feeling that is there a
way to streamline the poll where someone
could set it up I'm that I'm the only
one that's all I'm doing is the poll
okay picking coconuts in Barbados the
streamlined is it's gonna get man it is
Wednesday shots are
and now this is what I suspected the
early lead is going to uh fresh and fit
because those those are versatile and
they're so funny and Kafka is mostly
just creepy yeah I think that was gonna
be my vote personally yeah I voted for
for first-hand experience and it's
actually a bit it might be our first
blowout 80 are saying it is Wednesday
and coconuts and Barbados so kavcav just
yet another thing you've lost at in life
uh everybody hates you yeah and uh I
only wish the worst for you I'm the
first Jew on stage in Texas that cannot
be true
all right congratulations to um
fresh and fair I'm still seeing where's
people saying where's the pole this is
this is a you problem I'm sorry this had
13 000 yeah there's 13 000 votes the
votes are still coming in if you're not
seeing the poll you need to figure out
what's going on with you calm down yeah
yeah because they're yelling at me
they're all yelling at me and it's like
bro listen they bully me and people see
the pole the bad pole
Dan you're acting like someone just told
them that their mom died
[Laughter]
um yeah the the poll should be in the
chat
they've been good polls then thank you
thank you for saying so finally your
vacation the first one was too short go
ahead and refresh or whatever like uh or
or try on a different platform
um but uh if you're not seeing the poll
it's the poll's there it's at the top
holds the chat you'll see it there with
peace and love but yeah we have 15 000
votes so we're getting plenty of votes
here yeah
congratulations to fresh and fit let's
move it on keep it moving
here we have an interesting bracket we
have ladies and gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists oh I love that he's
welcome this is from CPAC the
conservative uh rally and these
Psychopaths I guess we're trying to do
stick yeah but they literally just
introduced themselves as domestic
terrorists and um
fascinating moment ladies and gentlemen
we are all domestic terrorists
they've been writing I mean God's sake
the guys this was not a welcome oh yeah
look at this we are oh my gosh dictator
oh my God I like to call this an intro
song Bite like right off the bat because
we play every leftovers you know you
can't start a show without it yeah so I
mean it is I love it I love that one
it's powerful it's powerful standby
but I think the one it's up against is
actually pretty strong now the story
here this is our son Theodore um
he was he heard me say the f word [ __ ]
yeah and uh he started doing jokes with
it where he would come up to me get
right in my face like this and I'd be
like what what is it Theodore and he
goes
and then I start laughing because it's
so funny yeah and so I'm trying to I
have to convince him that you can't say
that but also while laughing because it
was funny it was a really funny like I
feel like it was a maybe a two week or
something like that a period where I
discovered it and then we had to go
through like laughing because it was so
funny but then telling like ourselves
let's not laugh we can't laugh because
then he wants to do it more now we
actually learn he doesn't say it anymore
yeah and sometimes if he hears us say a
word that he thinks it's not appropriate
he'll ask can I say that because Daddy
can I say this yeah and if we say no
yeah you can say that word and I yeah he
hasn't said it since no he's he's a good
boy with that he goes Daddy
he sounds so different he was so much
younger but one more time
I was able to capture it because it was
so funny but there it is there's two
strong Predators our son versus
um the whole uh domestic terrorist
movement on the conservative branch of a
conservative movement of America that
stuff we are all domestic terrorists
let's put it to the vote for me I guess
as much as I think that should I should
I talk about myself okay as much as I
think that the theater one is so iconic
I feel like the domestic terrorists we
use a lot more on the show yeah for sure
so I kind of feel like
I would let it win for that by the way
thank you Bill Simmons for the 50 gifted
you are
can I show something to mobile users see
this big blue thing oh it's at the
bottom that's that's the poll if they're
on mobile yeah click one no I want
Theodore there you go so by the way
um that's good baby thank you for
showing that because that might have
been a lot of the people well weird
because I haven't seen one yet so really
you're probably right can you show me
again and if you're on desktop oh
somebody just donated this 10 right here
it's right there somebody just donated
ten dollars to say what a b just said so
thank you for the donation and uh sorry
buddy I'm sorry baby just told you
that's what I do well no he says he said
there's a little icon on the top of the
chat that has three lines press that and
click the options show top charts oh oh
that was stealing it good point users
maybe you're interested
now here's the poll we have again 16 000
votes so there's plenty of votes coming
in here uh what the [ __ ] now this is
somewhat close not very but Theodore has
taken it down actually with what the
[ __ ] oh wow it's a sweet moment it's a
tender beautiful I personally voted for
theater
because uh
I'll always vote for Theodore I'll Crow
said Danica are you making me look bad
are you right you had good reason oh my
god oh if you can't see your phone maybe
get upside down
no no no it's fine it's done and it was
well congratulations Theodore sent that
message
yo could I get a Tylenol from someone
have access to something like that yo
Metamucil just said stunning poles thank
you madam music
all right let's move on we gotta we
gotta keep all right so we're calling it
for Theodore here we go thank you thank
you there it is so now okay here's a
two powerful contenders this is a recent
the thing about it me and Adidas
powerful Kanye West has been giving
unfortunately
um wants me dead but at the same time
wonderful sound bites right so you have
to weigh the pros and cons but here he
is it's just like oh hit the disavow
thing
huh
yeah
[Music]
what's in the leftovers they're gonna
[ __ ] they're gonna they're such
should I just play the sound bite would
that be uh just say it yeah just play
the sound bites then sir now what
but play the whole thing yeah play them
all
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me I could literally
say anti-semitic [ __ ] and they can't
drop now what oh so good then the now
what cracks you up every [ __ ] time
right every time I play it you laugh at
it
oh this is well don't you have more like
I love Hitler yay is it all in the same
that's a package Kanye hits the juice
pack go ahead stop dissing the Nazis all
the time yes there's a lot of things
that I love about Hitler
if he even hits it
love love about Hitler and I love these
sound bites
good entry from Kanye West yeah he lost
it all but gained some great sound bites
in the process
here's a friend of the show PNP has
taken our hearts and uh our hearts were
found uh drunk driving and he freaked
them off for president
Gotham is fully stacked with villains
thank you to our boy PNP let's go
I want to see
seven to eight months we announced ready
for trial on this case we're ready to go
forward and beat the charges and I'm
pleased to announce that
once once he's done with probation it's
going to be gone off his record once we
expunge it how you feel I feel great
appreciate you sorry but there's the
iconic one is right here look at this
one wait where's the one with that dude
got dragged out by the jaws of life I
always say that this is what I was
laughing this is my boy
so good oh my God
yeah I did on that probably better to
watch The Source than the
my dumbass commentary over commentary
all right right right right right
they can watch how many space who he who
yeah I can't I can't again
here maybe y'all can find the video
you don't want to watch us react to it
it's so funny no that was when it became
a sound bite okay I guess okay maybe
you're right but it's like it was just
the moment this is when it became an
iconic thing I guess I wasn't sure if it
was
every video yeah you know you know it's
a lot
okay wait that's the one where he
doesn't actually say let's go you're
right holy [ __ ] yeah
I think that's just the one that like
really killed us like yeah we
right here laughing let's just watch it
then you're right we should watch this
let's go
yeah yeah thank you wait what a nice
Courthouse yo this is awesome
he was charged with the second time DUI
he has more on his Instagram I'm
watching through them right now okay let
me know if there's any good ones
so the top comment on this one is no
keep this man off the road uh he
admittedly overdosed on multiple
different oh this this is I think this
is the one it's tough It's Not Easy to
see because it's like audience to it he
did all this drugs that night
he crashed with two other cars
I can't
[Laughter]
do psychosis
this man ran over a whole family on the
island
he was block out drunk tested positive
for PCP yeah so anyway he this is our
boy PNP he gets the parents off and he
says let's go let's go let's go let's go
far away from this guy all right that's
really cool because the let's go it's
just become like
almost like we finish every sentence
well again they have deep lore let's go
has deep lore Kanye was a later entry
yeah but it is but it is very good it is
very good it's very versatile as well so
I have the PNP one also on quick trigger
as well okay because it's you know not
just saying absolutely no that's
important to say uh so I would be very
disappointed if it wasn't this one-sided
this ball well you guys know what this
one side I just put up the pole and it's
uh PMP has this BNB has this by a lot
it's a bit it's a bit of a blowout
let's go is winning but I do want to say
let's go is like it's almost like hello
and goodbye in our language yeah like in
in Hebrew shalom means hello ended by so
we're rewriting language let's go it's
the greeting uh but that being said I
don't want to Discount Kanye's entry
because it is so funny and it's so good
you know he just he met he just
he got matched up with PMP and he just
never had a chance but congratulations
in the Nazis all the time yeah yeah yeah
sure sure
here's one of my faves of the Year okay
these are two really good ones but one
of these is my fave you guys are gonna
love this one
oh this is the one we got cleaned for
last time
[ __ ] God they're so annoying the
streamies claimed us I don't know if I
told you guys this they claimed our
[ __ ] podcast for showing this dumbass
speech they dropped it but okay but I
got it they dropped it then that's good
should I just play the sound bites I'm
gonna play I gotta play it
so this is the fousey package this is
his great acceptance speech where he
says I felt gay and again cultural
phenomenon
first off I want to dedicate this award
to the dof rubber as the best family on
YouTube
second off this year I became one of the
most hated YouTubers on the platform
that's maybe because I let ricegum punch
me in the face or maybe because I came
out and said 99 of the pranks on YouTube
are fake but I want to say this for a
long time I looked at myself in the
mirror and I based myself based on what
I read on the comments I felt worthless
I felt ugly I felt gay I felt that no
like that's been something they told me
it really it actually makes me laugh
yeah and I've watched it a thousand
every time it's just so magical how he
tries to stick the landing but you can't
well and like based on what they told me
I still can't believe that when it
actually came out like we didn't even
know about it yeah and then a b just
randomly
said have you guys seen that yeah did
that is that how that came up yeah
during one of our shows wow
wow it was in the Streamys the
um for worst uh
award show
wow yeah I don't think fousey was on our
radar back in the day when he was being
like quote unquote exposed game I
personally felt bad luck we always felt
bad yeah so we kind of like stared away
but
um
but this is just phenomenal I mean it
really is just a tour de force and also
hit the other fousey entry has
unbelievable staying power as well and
you wouldn't think that it would be so
powerful
um but it is here it is good okay now
this is the best this is just one more
stick try it he was giving me cheese
this video is so [ __ ] funny we
watched this whole damn thank God we
preserved it because this is they got
they deleted this they did yeah the the
keemstar movie is what it was titled uh
has been buried oh I think I we haven't
seen the episode of you guys watching
this oh God it was every scene was like
pure gold we spent like a whole episode
reacting to them oh my God movie and uh
so here let me break it down for you
because it's episode yeah I think it was
a zoom episode it was like uh okay
because somebody had covered I had
covert at the time yeah so
Lucy's coming out to keemstar's house
okay like a documentary about him okay
and keemstar prepared groceries for him
and what the groceries was was beef
jerky and a plate of syrup that they
were eating with a fork it's just a
fashion of plate and just a puddle of
syrup poured on it and then just with
the fork just kind of Dipping the fork
he's the king of hospitality but what
but then it's so crazy then fousey tries
something I think it was beef jerky and
he says no it's cheese oh it's cheese
yes that he got from with the beef jerky
and he says it tastes like beef jerky it
tastes like beef jerky and it's such a
thing it's so funny I don't know why
that's good okay now this is the best
this is just regular cheese
keeps giving me cheese that should have
been a sound bite
maybe next year I mean we can make it a
thing it tastes like be jerky yeah yeah
that's a pepper stick
um
I don't know it's so funny it's so great
it tastes like beef Jerk it tastes like
beef jerky I said I need to go back and
watch this whole thing because I can't I
gotta see the syrup with forks there was
honestly so much ELO it's like the whole
video is so funny like somebody's
filming him and he's literally dipping a
fork into a tiny little dollop of syrup
why because you gotta eat it together
with the syrup apparently oh my God and
any food segment we do I always play
that like we're doing a taste test you
know everything tastes like you jerky
this is true it could it tastes like
everything tastes like beef jerky
yeah so those are two of my faves of the
whole year yeah and I think he's gonna
go a long way but the other one is
actually a really interesting entry one
that we use a lot and one that really
Dan one that really hit hard this is
from Gideon uh
who dubbed Dan
W Dan Wan they know you Damn W
Dan Wayne
yeah
and you know this moment actually
reverberated a lot because I started
using the W's yeah yeah it became a huge
thing yeah kind of like the let's go you
know in a way this became part of our
daily language yeah it's a tour de force
it's a cultural tournament it kind of
changed our chat to like a twitch chat
yeah
that's when my name changed to lb
nobody calls you lb I've never seen LP
nobody call you
web
WWE The Warner Bros web Elvis okay can
we get some pizza please I mean like I
know y'all actually ready that's true
actually if we're gonna last another
three hours on this [ __ ] yeah
no I don't think it'll be that long oh
she's on it Sam [ __ ] with me where's
the pizza
you got sound bites me asking for pizza
all right I'm gonna pop up the poll yeah
so I'm again Gideon had a huge impact on
us but those fouseytubes are one of my
favorites of the whole year uh frankly
it even though this is like my sound
bite because it's about me I
I gotta go with fousey too because I
think I mean
all of that is just plus the beef jerky
thing too
I mean that that might have been my
favorite episode this year like the
hardest they left
I felt gay one it literally makes me
laugh every [ __ ] time yay wait Sam
you already ordered you're such a legend
what the hell oh
I felt gay that's right like
and like that's based on what they told
me and it does appear to be a blowout
fousey
yeah with that 80 sitting at 84
currently that's with 9 000 votes so
that's a clean win for fousey I'm not
surprised I think that that one is like
it still makes me laugh maybe the most
yeah I think that this could be a
contender for a whole right I think yeah
boozy Howie yeah and what was the other
one that we just opmp like those are all
like favorites keep it going Jack
it tastes like beef jerky
worthless I like when you go when you
ugly yeah I felt gay my favorite is when
you space them out I felt that note of
them we're just talking about something
but then you space it out through the
it's like I felt worthless I felt
worthless and then give it a beat you
know we keep talking
and we keep talking yeah yeah
that's based on what they told me
yeah so congratulations foosi I'm really
happy to see you picking dubs and Gideon
no no offense no no you had a great
moment that meant a lot to us it
affected the whole epic man yeah
it was it like five times when we went
to Arizona we were sitting in the hotel
and every time I saw him like should I
just go up to him and ask him how he
feels I was like I don't want to be like
YouTube prankster right he might be down
I ran into him once I told this story
but when we lived in Encino I ran into
them
his face was all [ __ ] up and he got
like dental surgery
what I think it's all [ __ ] up on like
painkillers yeah rubbing his nose twice
I know from boxing so surreal I was
walking the dogs from boxing he also got
para beat up price Hall that one time
too oh yeah he got decked on uh you can
speed up a lot I'm starting to think
maybe I could beat his ass
frankly maybe I've been up in the boxing
ring having seen him in the ring he's
actually he was he's fit and he's taller
than I thought he was too
yeah but anyway congrats fousey you are
the king for that one
now
moving on to the next bracket this one
is pretty interesting
here's our keemstar package oh powerful
contender
this one is from the cursed Zoom call
where he admitted to um yo bro I'm at
this high school girl that was hot as
[ __ ] tonight
he actually said that [ __ ] right and so
it's a fantastic sound but it came
really late in the year yes I think
going into next year's act we could have
a lot of application for that yeah yeah
but uh
he was put forward for our consideration
for 2022 so for better or worse uh hit
me with all the keemstar packages though
you got some prime puss wow like I can't
really be me bro it's unfair right and I
got some like [ __ ]
20-something year old girl like on my
arm or whatever
it sounds like
like uh acoustic version or some [ __ ]
like it doesn't make sense
why do you look like a Power Ranger
you're so gay what
this is right try this right I'm
disabled
there's so many good ones that was of
course his story about how he was
partying with Leonardo DiCaprio okay can
I can I play my favorite one real quick
yeah please Leonardo DiCaprio yeah that
makes sense I don't know if we made it
makes sense that makes sense
I've been saying it all the time which
is very first I've been playing
that makes sense and to put it to
context he was making fun of some Girl
Eli and then the host is like oh she's
she's handicapped he goes oh that makes
sense oh my God
[Music]
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus that's a lot
so but it's a great package you know I
think the only
back foot here is that it came late in
the year yeah not had a lot of time to
play with these yeah thank you amen yeah
up against however is our very own love
um who was our favorite redneck of the
Year them Gators in Arizona
what the hecking dog now love you are
going to school it's time to pick out
your outfit for today's class these are
all very nice this reminds me of someone
like scarce maybe not that one this
would be too red too Swedish yes that's
Swedish what about this right here
[Music]
it's a great selection love and what a
fantastic bulletproof vest from the prop
department and now the teacher is going
to be coming in to give you a lesson
hello I'm Professor Dan
is a couple questions about America
multiple choice hey you just paid 25 for
access to the Golden Corral buffet line
do you a load up your tray with a
sensible portion and enjoy a classic
American meal demand to speak to the
manager 25 for a buffet are you insane
this is outrageous start throwing things
around or see load up your trade with 12
pounds of mac and cheese and ham that's
been sitting under a heat lamp for six
hours reward yourself until you're on
the verge of vomiting see that's right
yeah he's good he's good and we always
say that Love's at America weeaboo and
the weekends because we all know he has
to move here and we wanted to test his
american-ness
but where did their bears in Arizona
come in is that like it's in that video
he does a little
find the part where he's dancing because
that's the uh
where was it
this hole now we come to the end
blind colors true Patriots
honorary American
thank you all now uh love you you it's
time for you to head back
unfortunately time to hit the dusted
Trail see you all partners
[Music]
oh that's sad that's actually
heartbreaking
dissolve damn and here he is he's back
in Sweden I know where the heck and dog
is though guys but uh we heard it go
ahead please sounds like this what the
heck oh
and I don't want you to feel bad if you
get defeated uh love it's an honor just
to be in the top 32. yeah oh for sure
for sure but I don't think I will lose I
just want to say that those those very
well might be my favorite sound bites
we'll go ahead and play them all then
give us the full okay one second full
Gambit
anyone here from Arizona
uh yeah
God damn Rascal what the hecking dog
darn Garnet darn it wow
there's a lot of them yeah and you know
actually we put those together uh we
submitted it to the ucisc the Department
of Immigration they're gonna go and
consider that oh my God please Sam got a
pizza pie wow all right I'm throwing up
the pole yeah so that's keemstar thank
you so much Sam
so polls going up and again you're up
against the whole keemstar industrial
complex now I know so mainly Chad asked
about uh in a book huh I think yeah I
think that was in uh last year yeah it's
2021. what about the what about the come
everywhere in my room
is that this year I come in my room
um I don't think I think that was last
year no it's a Love Song by far yeah
that was when you had the fika fish in
your room was that last how are you no
there must have been when I came about
probably everywhere in my room oh it's
you oh
listen go ahead Dan I got pitched in my
mouth well listen
I wouldn't worry too much because you
are winning my friend currently sitting
at 72 with 11 000 votes
uh yeah I don't think Keem is overcoming
this
yeah I mean I love those game bites but
man anyone here from Arizona I have not
been able to stop seeing for like the
last 10 months it's hard to argue with
that I would say you won handily it was
70 to 30. uh congratulations lover thank
you thank you that was
a strong competitor right there yeah all
our package also you said at the top of
it these are the keems are too new I
feel like they're too new yeah but have
more time it's a shame like I wonder if
they should get a
um a grandfathered into next year's I'm
sure he'll say some more [ __ ] where
we're gonna use it yeah but I love I'm
so glad that you're you're taking a look
thank you I love it I appreciate that
yeah we're at 15 000. it's not the ratio
isn't moving I'm gonna go ahead and call
it congrats brother
[Music]
so thank you guys we're working through
here the bracket let's take a look at
the bracket okay
zoom out
wow
wow you see we have a lot of ground to
cover guys
wow so let's see here up next okay
this is a strong one damn
we got weights and fish God I love these
both
um kind of a late entry too but a
powerful one
a couple months ago no fisherman was
cheating
actually and stealing a significant
amount of prize money is putting big old
weights in the fish and well he got
caught there we go
so there it is weights and fish
go ahead Zach
that's a good one
[Music]
um
what do you think Dan I mean I know you
you really care about that one mm-hmm
uh I mean you know it's simple it's
straightforward there's not nearly as
much Nuance it's not part of a package
it's just a standalone but it's just so
powerful the way that he says it I
actually think it's really versatile
because anytime there's like Shenanigans
exactly it's very useful it is
there we go
yeah but up next is our very own white
Club Gabe who made a cameo that was uh
just an absolute slam dunk someone
asked for him to send their condolences
on their mom who passed away on a Friday
no less
yeah but here's Gabe's uh Cameo response
Randy
I know your dad's a special person to
you Randy I want to wish you the best
sometimes life doesn't go on forever
everybody has to go sometime Randy [ __ ]
yeah I'm sorry about your tragic loss
but Randy I know good things gonna
happen special things gonna happen to
you Randy because you're the best yeah
you're the best customer to serve the
best [ __ ] yeah hey Randy I heard from
Abby about your dad who oh
[ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah ready you're the best
sexy [ __ ] yeah cause it's Friday
cheers ready
something Good's gonna happen to you
that streamer should have taken a lesson
from Gabe that's how you handle some sad
news on a Friday yeah Dave's the king of
Friday yeah I'm sorry to hear that your
mother passed away [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah
vegetarian for them oh I see you guys
too that'd be good you [ __ ] with mine
the pineapple jalapeno black olive nice
yeah uh I recently gave it another
chance because I you had made us try it
years ago at the old studio and I wasn't
feeling it but I tried it again recently
I was like you know what hmm that's a
killer combo it's good it's good you
know what you're talking about thank you
so much I appreciate it I see more and
more people coming around to it
so um weights and fish first uh
sorry about your dad passing away hit us
what about the sound bites uh
[ __ ] Lisa for the 20 gifted
loved that thank you so much so there's
two more in the game package there's the
the hasta la vista and then there's the
uh how you doing
that strengthens the I think this one is
not even a close call in my opinion well
I just threw up the poll and already
this is the closest round we've had so
far
away I don't see it I don't see the pole
on my screen oh bad pole wait oh there
it is
so oh my God this is close yeah you got
a nail biter here there's our first nail
biter of the Season yep WOW 7 000 votes
in hmm
44 weights and fish
Wow versus 57 I'm sorry about your dad's
loss Gabe White Cloud Gabe this is a
close one here guys now Gabe is taking
an early lead 9 000 votes in
fairly commanding okay the the Gap is
widening Gabe is really taking it home
here on the home stretches well 11 000
votes 59 for Gabe that was close though
it was close it was within a couple
points weights and fish is a great entry
but that whole package that gave put
input for this year was phenomenal
phenomenal yeah
all right I think we can call it 15 000
votes white clock gave a 59
congratulations
he's the best and I recommend y'all
check out his Cameo if you have any
deaths in the family or um
I didn't care about illnesses which is
on that girl Cameo from Gabe the one
that commented in that twitch chat I
know
that would be nice yeah
that would be nice
sorry your mom died
you big old lesbian uh yeah that one's
so funny yeah
so wait you got a sound bite Gabe saying
you're big old lesbian where is that
from
someone else did one where they
her friend was diagnosed with an
incurable illness yeah or something
and he just kept calling her a big old
lesbian
it's awesome
he was following instructions
all right moving on oh man
wow this one's gonna this one's gonna be
close that's a tough one Jordan Peterson
of course is been a big topic this year
and the man just gives and gives and
gives the sound bites this has got to be
a whole package yeah Jordan has got so
many great moments this year oh yeah I
think I have the most amount of sound
bites in the Jordan Peterson category
there's a lot of them so here's the one
that uh
a lot I think had a more cultural impact
a lot of people were reacting to this
moralists we'll see and I'm not taking
down that tweet or acknowledging that my
tweet violated the Twitter rules up
yours woke moralists we'll see who
cancels whom Twitter's a race
[Music]
dude yeah I don't know how it's not a
parody either it's like when I was
trying to learn how to act for the
um payday voiceover that we have to do
and they're like be more expressive and
you have to like try to like really push
it so it's like up yours
yeah I saw comments saying they thought
it was AI generated until they saw it
seriously I just saw it on Twitter it
sounds like it yeah he goes he goes
rules
the way he said that it's so crazy
sounding what rules sons of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah but that's Jordan's voice he's just
the way he is
so this one was probably contributed to
that well trying to use understand and
mask Twitter's a rat hole
not anymore thank you Daddy Elon so go
ahead and play some of his other ones
there we'll see who cancels who maybe
will start to cry I'm in pain
ouchy no
Eternal ground sitting by the bank of a
swimming pool which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly my
God had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair she was stroking herself
absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
you can't be push this at my face
I raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand s tier finally unwilling to
hurt whatever's going on downstairs
we've played that far recently unedited
um the guest ever guess we've had the
the
girl who did your Mohawk oh yeah she was
like what the [ __ ] she was like tripping
out behind the best faces Dan if you
want veggie you can have these because
uh he just hooked me up with one of the
gluten-free ones uh which is also
vegetable yeah I mean there's other
varieties of pizza right but you're the
worst shut the [ __ ] up isn't this here
no worries
so so you don't need it I'll take it to
defend you from it literally from The
Joker literally thank you thank you
thank you time to invest
yeah so obviously that
is one of the best yeah
one of the best entries my oh [ __ ] here
we go again and Annie Williams
my mom died 11 years ago when I was nine
anyway everybody remembered Dan is a
sexy man please give Dan this money
I took a left turn what the [ __ ]
I read that how much money everybody
remember
Don't You Dare Forget that but what
could beat that
one of the best soundby packages
well well
there is something that can compete
really
here it is
here's another package it's Andrew Cuomo
plus the FIFA president I do love that
both
um
empathizing in moments of great stress
here's Andrew Cuomo as a New Yorker I am
a Muslim
as a New Yorker I am Jewish as a New
Yorker I am black I am gay I am disabled
I am a woman seeking to control her
health and her choices because as a New
Yorker We Are One Community
as a New Yorker what's so fast I just
love it is that Andrew Cuomo
and the FIFA president
gave almost the same speech yeah right
but
um as much as Andrews is funny this
guy's even funnier
this dude's talking about how he was
bullied for having red hair so he
understands what's it like
what's it like to be like a migrant
worker whose passport is stolen
before starting to give moral lessons
to people listen to this guy before stop
dude this guy's straight up like a Saudi
mobster the way I think to give more
lessons
to people today
I have very strong feelings I can tell
you that
today I feel
Qatari
today I feel
Arab
um
today I feel African go on
today I feel gay
laughs
today I feel disabled
yeah it's incredible
do you think it's like I feel a speech
writer a freelancer they both hired dude
they must have got that the same guy on
fiber yeah exactly because that did not
play well the first time
I I feel like a migrant migrant work
yeah
I'm so sorry I'm high the same girl says
I love you all also Ethan please try to
say my name Ani Johnny
it's like Bonnie without the bee yeah
honey
it's like so much Darth Vader's nickname
and he's a little slave boy so you have
time
you know when the uh Jewish coded uh
hideous alien man uh who holds him as a
slave Phantom Menace I have no idea you
know what I'm talking about episode one
honey
yes exactly that's the process so um
I am a Muslim I am Jewish I am black
disabled FIFA Prez
versus so hard first Jordan Peterson
today I feel disabled these are
finalists this this is hard today I feel
uh gay he hesitated with that one
because he's like am I really saying
this [ __ ] thinks about it before too
you know
so here we go gosh I don't know who to
vote for actually I'm gonna think about
this
feel like yeah I voted for Jordan yeah
and it's such a shame because I love
those sound bikes I know I am but I feel
like
it's so funny
but they don't they don't they don't hit
on the same level
Jules said this in the chat said this is
Sophie's choice for me yeah I mean yeah
is it gonna get tough it's only going to
get harder from here guys keep your
hands off my [ __ ] car
I think there's something so special
about Jordan being this uh great
right-wing thinker yeah and
simultaneously being such a [ __ ]
buffoon yeah literate inarticulate [ __ ]
nonsensical
ouchy I did not put myself
I heard ouching there's a dude on
Twitter I think his name is uh very tall
Bart and pretty much all he posts is
chopped up edits of Jordan Peterson and
they're really [ __ ] funny I don't
believe that ouch yeah the ouchy one
came from one of his videos I'm in pain
ouchy I would follow that up like that
oh my God but I'm banned
so there it is um you know Angel Cuomo
you've lost everything
um
I wish I could give you this dub but uh
yeah unfortunately it's going to Jordan
I am Jewish you're not attorney you're
Italian I am disabled
katari katari
it's really saying a fun farewell to a
friend there but uh Jordan advances
congrats buddy friend of the show Jordan
Peterson
yeah
um okay
here's a here's a dark horse
um AV breathed life into this one
let's take a look
like Waka Flocka yeah
[ __ ] that's spanking [ __ ]
yeah
so Flocka vodka do you want to come play
it EB you want to do the honors
that's all you no please come seriously
come on come on come on
there we go it's true
own it
they've been walking around
he's sitting in Zaxby he's looking for
the button there
very good very good you had a great
moment with those flockas
yeah it's just one all right now okay
all right we're good we're good on it we
get it
he had a great moment and Zach's absence
AV stepped in and with one magical Touch
of his finger yeah he endeared everyone
to the Flocka I remember yeah because at
first I was a little nervous very
intimidating I was like you know what
let me just make a meme out of it I saw
that Flocka I was like this one we
haven't used and I went for it now you
were saying you think flakka could win
not that it could win I hope he doesn't
win to be honest but I think you could
go further than you think but I do have
a tough competitor so I don't know
that's kind of where I was going with
this because everybody loves Flocka and
you'd think that'd be a shoe-in yeah but
you'd be wrong because it's going Head
to Head
with Will Smith slaps Chris Rock oh [ __ ]
wow which was one of the biggest moments
of the year
and uh the sounds were just unbelievable
let's play it I love you yeah Jane two
can't wait to see it all right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I can't get over how unoffensive that
joke is
GI Jane too the whole thing so bizarre
he was laughing at first she looked
pissed he looked happy yeah
yeah that was a that was a nice one okay
I'm out here oh Richard
I can't watch it
oh wow
wow it's so disturbing Will Smith just
smack the [ __ ] out of me
it is so [ __ ] up it's actually it's
actually so psycho um
is he working is Will Smith had a job
yeah yeah oh yeah he's coming out on one
of the late nights like talking about it
about this slap did he give something to
Will Smith's credit
his apology was very genuine he fully
owned it said that was super [ __ ] up
with me you know what I mean not to
defend the action but like did we watch
his apology no so there's something I
think we covered it yeah I mean there's
so many reasons that we didn't talk
about what do you say maybe if something
recent I don't think it was very sincere
from what I saw people talking about it
you know what's interesting is Chris
Rock I don't think has really spoken
about it yet
I think he did it as stand-up shows a
little bit I remember reading about that
brother definitely did yeah his brother
super vocals say that again Zach
but that here comes the sound bites here
this guy's name out your [ __ ] mouth
wow dude yeah it was a GI changer
I'm going to okay
well I could oh okay yeah say it I wish
you said it man
and there it is uh and of course Zach
did all kinds of fun remixing back there
go ahead Zach
okay okay
so pretty useful stuff there
um so I mean
two battles we got Flocka first keep my
wife staying out of your mouth here it
is
I personally really like that keep
[ __ ] my mouth
lots of flakkas in chat though so
you never know which way it's going to
go here at the annual sound bite 2022
Olympics today we honor
our great competitors yeah I don't see
the poll is it up it is fortnite somehow
still a little bit ahead wait I don't
see the people why the [ __ ] could only
see the pool okay there it is took so
long
all right so we have a little bit of a
of a close race yeah so everybody your
vote does matter Flocka's in a in a you
underestimate the Flocka Army block is
in a slight lead here now Will Smith
um you need to Rally some votes is there
anything you want to say in support of
yourself
Will Smith is inviting you to uh fellate
his mouth or yeah so that's a good offer
if anyone's interested in that okay
yeah so it's 57 flock of 43 Will Smith
keep [ __ ] my mouth it's close maybe
there yet but hold the line Boys Will
Smith is going to need some movement if
we're gonna keep this pool open 13 000
votes no I'm going to okay I'm waiting
for some updates here 14 000 no change
let's wait for 15 000 but uh steady it's
looking good for Flocka looking very
good for flog here Will Smith just
cannot keep up and I'm well I'm gonna
call it right now that's a dub for
Flocka well
what a fantastic thank you guys here for
Will Smith but uh
the power of the Flocka the power of the
Flocka was too strong to overcome I
think it's the whole context of it the
fact that
it's a b doing the sound bites for Zach
and just like everything about it was so
funny you know what I just remember too
there was the additional meme when you
were like homesick or something yeah you
got didn't you get coveted or you were
just normal sick or something I got my
uh wisdom teeth I was the wisdom teeth
and he was doing the show from home and
he was calling it on zoom and then he
start he started playing the flock of
sound bite really low but like Audible
and you're like where's the flock
yeah it it became like my sub sound on
Twitch just flocking okay there you go
so if someone donates like 20 Subs they
have to hear it Non-Stop
there it is Flocka
congratulations to uh a b and Hannibal
beerus for that strong entry there
moving on we have Andrew Tate who also
had a big gear lots of sounds to choose
from with Andrew Tay it's your girl
that's a good one
he's the perfect Alpha
uh
if that's the game if you're into being
locked in a basement and forced into sex
work
but let's go ahead and play
are we good why not you guys need help
with me how so I need money huh I'm not
actually rich no way yeah it's all a
[ __ ] scam wow even my house is a scam
what do you mean by that I live in a
Toyota Camry wow but I need an iPhone
how much would that cost 100 150. could
we kick it for a little bit we'll smoke
a cigar out there and talk about it yeah
no problem so how do you
morally cheat here's the thing you don't
really look I could sleep with thousands
of women I just think it's boring Korea
yeah where's the uh uh suck a little bit
a day it's in there it's uh yeah I'd
rather [ __ ] dudes oh hell no [ __ ] yes
how does that work well I'm a man of God
I read the Bible I go to church oh what
happened bro he went straight to uh he
went straight to Islam this wasn't even
that long ago
damn Jesus just wasn't cutting it huh
he thought Jesus was too beta right yeah
he yeah he's kind of right God to be
honest he has a point that's awesome but
I also suck a little bit of Dick
God wants the the man the masculine
males so there it is yeah a little bit
of Dick wasn't actually something he
said
uh yeah it was oh he said it it was
mashed together but there's no no that's
a clean sound bite it's he was saying it
in the context of like he was speaking
oh if I'm a girl and I want to suck a
little bit of dick or whatever yeah but
that's not like
edited so wait different bits together
I wonder where he was going with that
thought if I was a girl and sucked a
little bit of dick
I don't remember the exact there was
also a lot that that came from that and
we we actually talked about this a lot
uh for this as an entry like there's
this that's the game
which is versatile I'm a bomb right I'm
a boss oh yeah and then it doesn't exist
yeah sparkling water sparkling water and
then obviously
that one's kind of the best
but I hate to do this but Andrew Tate is
up against his little homie yes or no
and his uh lover uh and and uh a partner
and they perform together yeah yeah this
is Aiden Ross
saying I'm 21 [ __ ] you what you wouldn't
expect
to be so useful but somehow sneaks into
every episode at the perfect time I
don't get it but here it is uh with
piece them up to Aiden Ross I thought
his interviewer was horrible I mean oh
my God bro
why do you put this guy in my [ __ ]
chat bro bro
I mean I don't really this video is so
weird
he's reacting to him reacting to what I
said why are you reacting to it again we
have you know much you know
I mean you're six years old bro HD3 you
have the worst podcast on YouTube
where you literally hate your life all
you do is hate on other people and put
them down one look at your own podcast
it's horrible nobody watches it it's
boring I tried putting it on I fell
asleep on God all my life oh God sucks
bro it sucks get some new guests on get
some [ __ ] [ __ ] on that [ __ ] you
need something on there I don't even
know bro you like retire bro at this
point just [ __ ] retire you suck your
ass you hate your life
I'm 21. [ __ ] you
it's quite a it's quite a way to end a
sentence yeah he realized he's like he's
like [ __ ] everything I said is kind of
stupid I'm 21. don't blame me [ __ ]
dumbass which is fair 21 is very young
it is very young it is kind of a good
way to follow up that side yeah [ __ ]
yeah so Aiden I don't know who's gonna
take this one you got Aiden and Andrew
Tate and it's just too eminently
unlikable people head to head
here we go I'm throwing up the ball shut
up and now they're about to compete like
top G Going uh
uh going in Raw on Hayden let's see who
can last the longest
where the Sheck sucks off a Hebrew
National yeah exactly exactly and then
just throwing uh Dan's favorite is uh
the Andrew Tate saying no no
no
it's so good you're so desperate enough
Kali I mean you got Aiden Ross
[ __ ] you I'm 21. it's not a lot by
itself but he but Zach does a lot with
it hmm
I feel like it's Tate for me I yeah I
think that voted tape the eight and
it'll sneak up like just the most random
places yeah right
right like when people say oh I have
21st birthday in chat you know I'm 21.
21. [ __ ] you
yeah I'm willing to call this at the
moment it's Andrew Tate by 68 it's a
fair big one and but this is the way
they wanted it because Andrew's the ball
yeah right right he's gonna yeah right
he's gonna abuse hot little twinks right
yeah and uh that's just the way they
would want it so I'm a bottom oh wait oh
never mind
I wonder if he does he Pro I wonder if
Aiden fits him and does he pull out yeah
I mean I'm the one getting Cloud here we
go well Andrew take congratulations 70
sorry Aiden Ross this just wasn't your
year we need to try to get somebody to
go undercover
into the Tate Army and try to get him to
say the word prolapse oh
it would be such a funny sound but I
don't know prolapse
we could probably engineer it prolapsing
with bubble water yeah
my [ __ ] prolapse I'm a man of
prolapsing roses are my favorite I love
roses
yeah but there it is uh Andrew
congratulations and you're you are only
21 Aiden so you have a lot of more years
to compete
and we'll certainly be looking looking
forward to that now wow this next
bracket is gonna be tough for you guys
this is this is pretty gnarly dude now
this one here is a late entry this
should be a complete blowout this is the
stupidest [ __ ] bracket now Dan first
of all he said I don't want the DPI in
and I said why what is wrong with you
the DPI goes in it'll be silly Sam why
do you get the DPI because it's so dumb
it's not that funny what it works
it's the owner of the mouse but like out
of nowhere in the middle of the show
your mouth starts talking
and the coolest voice like it makes no
sense I guess you didn't even know hot
the mouse's voice why is your mouth
I'm a [ __ ] bro you left early yesterday
I did Terrible Things to that mouth oh
Jesus just wash your hands
make sure to wash your hands before you
eat Matt shifts his uh my girlfriend
watches H3 and loves it why don't you
well you should watch it too bro you're
donating
what is this
they think this is the first time we
heard the DPI Voice by accident okay and
we didn't know what it was oh [ __ ] where
do you guys have that Intel not that
I've ever seen any other videos
congratulations
no it sounds like the same voice right
an ad popped up oh okay we have the
original the dog I remember this it
wasn't the DPI guy the mouse wasn't good
at you I don't think unless it was like
the software had just updated yeah that
was my uh oh my God the same exact voice
what on Earth was that
it probably is the same voice because
he's a professional voice
even if it was just an ad yeah let's
hear again congratulations
he goes congratulations I think it's the
most it has to be what so nobody ever
fessed up to it right because I was like
what happened well we wouldn't know it I
don't think anybody knew it genuinely
just came out of nowhere
also
we were [ __ ] up so yeah really Dan
you've been you have so much experience
you're this executive producer and you
got your mouse and interrupting the show
I've never seen that before it's just
rock rocket cones driver [ __ ] now
you know check your mouse is before you
go live oh look at that I just found the
setting to disable them no no no no no
bye-bye
so I can hear the voices here let me
play this congratulations
why is it like that congratulations I
just love to feel like what the [ __ ] is
that you I've ever used
congratulations
what on Earth was that but it stopped it
didn't finish if it was your mouse it
would have finished I think it was
stopped by everything maybe I don't know
I really don't know
beautiful
what on Earth
then it comes back
that's Wally that was a zombie yeah
okay I'm pretty sure that's Wally so
play the DPI
you got that attack
[ __ ] I don't got that bro
wait are you serious
no why would I that's all bam that's
Dan's Department
all right here we go here we go here we
go enabling sound here it comes 1 600
DPI
3200 to DPI
6400 DPI
8200 DPI and then all the way down 800
DPI now I'm gonna put something forward
I don't think it's the same voice no you
have generic like action movie voice
actors you can find them on Fiverr
they're kind of dime a dozen but here
listen is he a hookah smoker do you guys
have that Intel not that I've ever seen
it in my videos
congratulations
okay now I play it 1 600. it does sound
like yeah I think it's the same dude I
was just like him
congratulations
this mouse has way too much to say
[Laughter]
he's big time now he's he's voicing
every Mouse yeah across the world he's
in high demand
I don't know why it's so funny to me
yeah see in the sound settings there's
something called trophy notifications
and so the congratulations I don't know
what this I don't know can you look in
the files too much going on I will say
that day I was I was on your mouth who
doesn't need this
what is that thing wow what is that the
software is so over the top we're
[ __ ] Mouse man so I was on your
computer that day because you walked
away for a little bit so I don't know
maybe I pressed something oh maybe very
very likely is there a way to go into
the file on Windows and look for the
sounds
I mean yeah they probably are just like
wave files so you gotta find that we got
to close the case yeah okay all right
because that would be
you're probably right it probably is in
here somewhere and by the way funny that
somebody put that together too y'all
didn't catch that crazy for that
but anyway who we're back to the
competition we have 800 yeah hold on go
ahead oh I just opened up a whole can of
worms
I guess that makes sense because you can
custom set what the DPI levels are
there's there's ones for like every
level like there's ones we've never
heard before
Oh [ __ ] 200 DPI
DPI 400 DPI 800 1000 DPI 12 to 200 DPS
say hi does it go
seven thousand eight hundred DPS whoa
eight thousand DPI
gets it yeah
congratulations there it is you did it
yep You've Won every trophy wow it's
it's here oh my God
I never lost faith You've Won every
trophy there it is I found it
it was in here play it
congratulations
you did it what the [ __ ] okay that makes
the clip so much funnier now that we
know for sure what does it mean though I
don't know what a trophies what the [ __ ]
it's a mouse on the day that you guys
are high and don't know what's happening
right right right right on that day you
apparently collected a Trope we we
accomplished we did it guys we did it
any other interesting ones we want to
hear before we move on uh here we got
some profile stuff I don't know let's
see profile five profile
profile two oh oh here's okay
everybody's about to the panties are
about to drop
cents up oh that was disappointing I
thought he was gonna say sensitivity uh
did they not pay him for the second
syllable
sense sense well anyway it was profile
all right the camera lag by the way
there is a ton of vegetarian pizza back
there Dan uh I've had like four slices I
am good thank you okay but you guilted
me into giving you my beautiful my crown
you did out of your orange it was mean
he was handed him his gluten-free pizza
because there was nothing back there
maybe I misheard Sam I thought she said
that was the only one only vegetarian
one it literally said don't do it don't
do it I didn't want to call Sam out but
Sam told me that was the only vegetarian
one sorry Sam
KB's plotting again she's not here to
defend herself maybe I misheard her but
actually I don't care I got myself some
barbecue Pizza a barbecue chicken
I'm loving it there's there's mushrooms
back there you look all right we gotta
refocus because uh you guys okay well
show me the guy here at certain times
listen
we're on the DPI train here's one that
makes me laugh every [ __ ] time it is
so funny our president is back right
where he needs to be
uh here he is remember I was going to
say to use an expression we have to keep
our country gate prepared
and even just makes me laugh
this [ __ ] got coins on the
screen bro
s
remember I was going to say it's going
to use an expression we have to keep our
country gate
it's a shame in a way that we didn't
package all the gay ones because
but it was so hard we were go we
suggested that but yeah there was a lot
of back and forth on uh yeah
needed his own package yeah they don't
belong together right okay I'm throwing
up the poll round 11. so DPI I feel like
there's a blowout where's president
Trump
which do you think is going to win the
DPI of course Trump wants better well I
agree with that but you're gonna tell
our audience that the Trump one I feel
like they'll they'll make the right the
Trump one is so [ __ ] funny
wow I don't see the [ __ ] it shouldn't
have even included DPI man what you have
to oh no whoa we got a closed bed here
50 guys guys get your votes and it
matters do not let DPI win this I know
it's funny
but Trump keep our country gay prepared
the DPI is Legend we have we're at only
4 000 votes in it is close close 56 DPI
44 Trump get those vote matters it's
happening everything's happening right
now 6500 votes
not much movement 9 000 votes in it's
the same pretty close tick one towards
Trump just now okay we have some forward
movement DPS at 55 Trump 45 trying to
resist the DPI movement and it will not
happen you'll only make it longer Eli
you are you are literally causing this
direction right now now we found them
away from you we found the lore of the
congratulations 46 Trump it's moving in
Trump's favorite mouse was talking to
you guys and you didn't even know it he
said it's true he was always here
guys get your votes and it's too close
to call it right now it's 54 DPI 46
Trump this is our closest match today
we're huge this is important we only
have 14 000 votes guys
this is not even fair Zach didn't even
sound it sound by it right it's like it
should be the squad
no this is not like you guys are
sabotaging look Dan didn't want to play
I said you have to include it absolutely
guys get your votes in 46 Trump to 54
DPI it is too close to call when he's
not even a sound bite it's not even a
sign box I know but we're we're in the
minority here
this is a popular vote I stand I stand I
don't get it they're stealing I say it's
a sound bite yeah
and you trigger sound that's a song of
course
no people are arguing people are
debating well whatever to sound drop you
know what I mean what is life why don't
you just right how do you have to find
what is it is baby don't hurt me all
right guys I'm gonna have to wrap this
up if the Trump people don't get out
there and vote I think I think it's over
I mean make sound bites great again vote
for keep our country okay
dude now you all gonna [ __ ] vote down
it's an amazing sound bite
DPI I like it but it's stick Trump is
the real deal yeah I agree with you yeah
I mean I don't know [ __ ] I am gay is
the real deal Trump gay is like a funny
spin-off of the gay thing but it's not
at it
[Laughter]
stop moving hold on breaking news 47
Trump 53 we have 17 000 votes and guys
this is huge this could change the whole
formation everything the whole rest of
the tournament now let me ask you this
in the next bracket the winner of this
goes against a juggernaut who's going to
have a better chance DPI or keep our
country gay Brit I think Brit what
what's the next one I don't know well oh
okay I'm just saying the novelties
you guys are not even playing DPI at all
talk to Dan about that that's on Dan
this is sabotage
6400 can we watch the congratulations
200 DPI the more I hear that voice the
more
congratulations you've
what on Earth
I love how we just don't acknowledge it
probably figured it out [ __ ] yeah it
took us like several months but
the prep comes back and it makes me
laugh one also could argue that the
congratulations the way he hits that
it's different than like all the others
yeah congratulations
this is our closest one this is the
prison of your own making okay you
insisted on including DPI thank you
thank you Franklin I am a damn I'm a
free speech absolutely yeah absolutely I
put the options out there and I let the
people vote all right we got a colleague
because we've spent way too much time on
DPI all right congratulations DPI guy
answer your [ __ ] emails
I really want you to do some damn sound
for us
one more congratulations
come on more congratulations I mean I
guess we have to one more congrats
congratulations congratulations
but you know what's funny in the video
like the sound right before it like
there's a sound I don't know what that
was yeah it was me this is a Wally sound
bite that Zach's playing and then we
interrupted so exactly no but there's
like some sort of like what the Triumph
Triumph moment I think it was violations
all right let's move we gotta move on
okay okay we're gonna be here all night
you've won a trophy all right shut up
DPI guys congratulations answer their
[ __ ] emails dude I got a whole a lot
of work for you
all right Olivia it's happening
um this was Olivia's telling a story
about
um you were attacked by a dog
and she said what could all only come to
all of our minds in a moment of Crisis
right it's happening I was okay so I
went to a party on Saturday night my
friend and I went back to the house that
she's dog sitting at
um she was told that the dog
um had previous trauma but the owners
didn't tell her that she couldn't let
the dog out to go to the bathroom if she
brought someone over and it had been a
few hours so it was time for the dog to
go to the bathroom and as soon as she
opened the door of the crate the dog
instead of going straight out to the
backyard took a detour and came straight
for me and I like knew what was
happening because I was being charged by
a pit bull so I was just like kind of
yelling and then it got a hold of my arm
and the only thing I could think of to
say was I just like told my friend to
let her know it was an emergency I just
screamed it's happening
and she like grabbed the dog off of me
and I ran into the kitchen bleeding
there you go it's happening
and I've been in trouble since that and
I just came it's happening everybody
knows what it means yeah love it
um although
up against the one and only Kris Jenner
which one is that who is she or she was
telling her servants close the trunk I
love her so well so that they could have
more privacy here it is window rolled up
yeah but the trunk was open close closed
captioning
not
available
excuse me sir would you mind closing the
trunk for a moment thank you so much
it's not what you say it's how you say
no no
do you want to come in my car
it all sound like him it's kind of crazy
they all do even the moment in my car
blows the trunk so I don't I really
don't know which way to go with this one
I know you've got it's happening Olivia
our very own Olivia that one versus
close the trunk Kris Jenner anything you
want to say Olivia as the uh you could
open the voting please yeah I would like
to say
um
I think that Kris Jenner is the best I
think that she's the funniest in the
whole world and I'm going to be voting
for her today
okay an endorsement for her opponent
yeah wow classy yeah you want to come to
my good sportsmanship thank you very
much we love to see you personally I
vote Olivia oh well well I would vote if
the poll was open
foreign
polish bugged SOS
it's happening there it is okay no hmm
where am I Landing here
oh man
that's a tough yeah you want to come in
my car and close the trunk
I voted for Olivia because I have to
support our family
and actually Olivia
69 percent so far are agreeing it's
happening
thank you guys if you like Kris Jenner
better I'm urging you
I think it's hilarious
I went to a boxing match last weekend
and when I'm watching one of the fights
some guy next to me kept saying it's
happening and then like we're looking
and I was like is he just saying that or
is he referencing the show but then like
by the fourth time he's like it's
happening and then looking at me like I
was like okay yeah he's a fan yeah I
love that that's awesome
well Olivia congrats you took down Kris
Jenner Hello Olivia thank you so much I
never thought I'd see the day James
Charles are you proud of our our very
own Olivia oh
yeah thank you
so there yeah congratulations so moving
on
we have a package a ninja package oh
Ninja's been a Hot Topic here uh we've
been on a bit of a roller coaster from
being friends to him being a guard at a
guard Tower doing 360 no scopes on
prisoners
to coming all the way back around and is
that Kanye
what we came all the way but I don't
remember
I don't like him are we back from liking
him yeah where are you now
[ __ ] that dude I hate him oh okay oh
yeah well he's yelling at that kid I
don't know oh I did see that my wife's I
just got I just got done sucking milk
out of my wife's titties and you're
living in your basement
easy access no bra I got a smoking a hot
wife
I'm saying
sounds like it and you're gonna go to
bed and you're still gonna be a [ __ ]
loser he's 12 ninja that is crazy yeah
anyway
um here it is
oh I shot my oh oh my God
oh my God I can't control my goo
that's a good moment from Ninja really
good moment
we were talking uh me and Ian were
talking about this yesterday despite you
know him maybe being part of the SS or
whatever like
he is a theater kid he's very he emotes
from one to another he does silly voices
yeah no I'm getting like kind of I all I
see is just the clips that you guys show
I've never watched his actual stuff but
I'm getting like a Wendy Williams Vibe
because it's just like lots of like
silliness and funny voices and noises
we found more even yesterday looking for
some of these I cannot believe we missed
one that's just was posted especially on
the subreddit from oh well not so fresh
two months there's like a little bit
yeah
I got that can I get ah
[Music]
yeah oh my God by the way
yeah yeah I know I know but but wow the
consideration was beautiful though yeah
his iteration was very I'm drunk
um let's just hit me with the all the
sound bites of the Ninja ones that I
don't wanna have to
wow
am I Jewish I'm not I thought it was
free hello hello
say hello to the H3 podcast hello my
family Ethan a b cam Dan hila and Elena
Olivia Sam Zach
that was windy
you can't sneak that back no that was
Ninja wait no ninja gave like he gave
Wendy wait that's ninja that's ninja
that's totally Wendy no no play The
Wendy one you have the windy one yep
hold on
oh
I play ninja is different
oh my God
and I I didn't know about this one I
said that he is giving me Wendy Williams
yeah wow okay
Zach play those back to back a few times
I'm not going to tell you which one or
you want me to tell you which one's
which just playing back to back you
don't
that's Ninja
that's Wendy yeah
I can't believe it wow
oh man I love it
well so clearly ninja that was windy
that was windy oh my God it's already 4
30. oh you play the fortnite valenciaga
how are we going fortnite Balenciaga can
someone stay later there
how late I'm not I mean we still have a
ways to go here yeah
we're almost down we're almost done with
the first round and then we can really
speed up one damn it we're kind of Wendy
Sam's listening she said that's not
Wendy no that was Ninja what the [ __ ]
it's blowing my mind yeah once we get
we're almost through the first bracket
and then we're gonna just go real fast
all right so uh this one is a dark horse
this next one I'm so freaking love this
one I giggle every goddamn time it is
leaving my friendships behind I know my
friendship's behind black willow and
Carrie that's the hard part leaving my
friendships behind black willow and
Carrie that thing is so they brutalized
this stuff leaving my friendships
I love it so I mean you've got basically
the whole Ninja complex package first
one beautiful man
who's leaving his friendships behind you
can also see on the WAV file they
stretched it out too like it's pretty
gnarly
oh really yeah
all right I'm Justice for Pokemon
yeah I agree with you uh I'm not I'm
anti-ninja yeah Justice for Pokemon
Emerald justice for all the Jews who
died in the Holocaust
all right I'm dropping I'm dropping the
poll
I'm not
I'm not some easy choice for me
well
[Music]
we're open guys let's get to those votes
in yeah
the Ninja
package versus leaving my friendships
Beyond
um leaving my friendships behind now I
see that ninjas taking a strong early
lead 71 to 29 leave my friendships
behind
I can't I'm a little disappointed but I
get
I get
why y'all are voting for Ninja
and uh
but at the same time I do think leaving
my friendships behind you though he's a
banger it's a banger
all right that is a blowout though
it's looking like yeah let's move it on
that's ten thousand votes so we could we
can lock it up so congratulations to
ninja who cannot control his goo or his
temper
or his or swinging or his sphincter
sphincter his drinking
his lawsuit threats too easy he can
however control his wife
who gives him uh
31 year old grown man on a Sunday night
drunk off the most says
yeah getting a note that uh
the behind
is a trans woman so we would like to
correct
the record on that one cornbread
cornbread ladies and gentlemen behind we
love it I voted for you cornbread so I
did as well yeah yeah
um all right let's keep it moving
congratulations
don't waste that sweet milk now this is
me saying it or the preacher you this is
you
sweet milk
absolutely unacceptable do not waste
that sweet milk
is just another I'll tell you what
temples dude I look so much heavier what
though Frick that's crazy
lick it off you bro if you dare waste
that the thing about Temple is like it
so there it is
as you guys know
semen is just another type of milk
semen is is another kind of milk so we
have that versus Jimmy Lee audio audio
which is happening really had a big
impact I think throughout the year Jimmy
Lee this was kind of Jimmy's year as
much as he is sexually harassing women
on on Instagram right now if we put that
aside he really is having a big year
hold it I wanted to check
you and my audio where's he you have
audio I mean and we watched this uh
yesterday was was it stop was yesterday
yeah yeah or two days ago but yeah and
it was I was done seeing stop react to
this [ __ ] and uh it's just so great so
there's also uh
foreign
don't waste that sweet milk versus audio
audio audio album Jimmy Lee there's
nothing I mean mine is fun whatever I
think it's not even my sound bite it's
from the preacher I use that more than
the [ __ ] preacher though I thought it
was him no it's you male Rook oh wow
it's another type I don't see I don't I
don't see it yet
is it a blowout I don't know why you
always see it after I always see it I'm
doing Jimmy oh yeah it's up there you
guys finally answered the call Jimmy Lee
I want to check audio audio audio
Jimmy Lee is taking a strong lead I
wasn't sure if people were getting Jimmy
Lee fatigue and we're just gonna spite
vote for me right but I'm happy to see
that the Superior Sound is winning Jimmy
Lee
handily defeating sweet milk 83 17
congratulations Jimmy uh let's move it
on to the to the next one Hassan
saying Adolf Hitler and kraka less than
three you know who is around in the
1900s Adolf Hitler dude
we do get that one in a lot and actually
he's wearing Teddy fresh in this clip
which makes it even better that is
awesome oh wow
that that goes a long way
uh also Hassan entering with kraka which
she was famously he was famously banned
on actually the same stream I'm sorry I
meant
oh this doesn't laugh and the laugh it's
like all from that laugh yeah it's like
a
[Laughter]
squeaky oh my God something
I just love it like pointed out if I
play that song by then we can get him
banned on Twitch again like when he
calls in you know
yeah so you have Hassan with some great
entries uh kraka and uh and you know
Adolf Hitler dude
but up next you have once again strong
opponent and liver king the king battle
of the two Alphas
um liver King coming in with
Primal subprimal milk they have a oat
milk because that's just bomb is oatmeal
real how are you gonna milk it out
I love that how are you gonna milk
enough
it's true it's a good question is it
real no it's not nope
um keep go play his hotel
never
done text that was another one I got
owned once again uh completely do you
feel like the news about him kind of
being a fake like ruins the sound bites
for you I mean to be fair I don't think
we respected him much to begin with yeah
so I don't I don't think it really
changes our perspective yeah
be good to go uh liver King now do you
have to have sex in a certain position
because you're so big and sometimes fat
guys have a problem they have to they
have to go into a certain position I
mean you're massive right and also I
don't know how well endowed you are but
like what's the situation with your how
what position do you have to go in a
position are you guys fully flexible
because you're both very muscular
um
never talk about my wife in this context
oh okay
[Music]
up to that point he had been
pretty uh yeah yeah that was a sudden
red line that was crossed theirs and
then he's like I'm over this
so yeah he started sweating when we were
playing the anyway so you got on one
hand you could throw up the pool we've
got Hassan Adolf Hitler dude and crack
up versus liver King How You Gonna milk
a note and never talk about my wife in
that context very strong Contender
absolutely here we go
I still don't know Dan
have you looked into that also in Silent
Library actually yes
um well Dan did in fact uh milk an oat
with Cam oh that's true but how do you
milk ano you just put it in water right
you just yeah it's it's uh
it's oat tea
okay think of it that way that's
probably a better term than uh it's Odie
or OT like like how you would make a
Earl Gray tea but oh but we don't but
without oh blender all right guys I'm
sure there's more to it than that guys
we're gonna wrap it up Adolf Hitler
Hassan is destroying liver King subprime
Olympic really Primal Hassan yeah I I
wasn't sure where it was going to go but
69 Hassan Adolf Hitler did in the laugh
he's got a lot of fans in the chat what
can you say I'm shocked but I mean I'm
no disrespect to that sound like but wow
I mean I know how are you gonna milk oh
don't talk about my wife those are good
ones I mean hit that hit the cracker a
couple times
I mean that one yeah that one it just
gets a lot of mine that's iconic that's
strong
and he's laughing yeah right yeah you
can tell you
can tell he really hates white people
the way he hits that
no but congrats congratulations to some
all right so um I believe we just have
one more round
so this is the last first round of like
yeah the initial oh I know who this one
is is an easy one it's a blob because
one of these I think is a main contender
we have oh Monsieur which is a great
sound bite don't get me wrong I mean I
don't even know where that's from
right and it's like some competition I
think it was from a skiing video and a
guy was hitting wasn't he like hitting
his balls on like the the flags as he
was going on I'll read you the
description it says French star Yannick
uh bear Trend straddles the gate and
takes a mean shot to the groin during
the FIS World Cup Super G race in Norway
and he enjoyed it
the guy
he definitely did not really
he's yelling oh oh the gate to the groin
for yanique bertrawn and you could hear
it
and if you're a man you could feel it
wow watch this again
another one I have on the quick trigger
yeah it gets a lot of play during ad
reads
I thought he said that after he got hit
no no no that's the commentary but it's
funny and as good as that one is I don't
think it's gonna have a chance against
our very own
Boby oh yeah
excuse me there's Bobby uh doing the
restarted gesture
as he is
losing
he's losing his mind that this girl only
has 500 stuff
the business days of the apology that
I'm supposed to be making
delayed because I'm sitting here
fighting for my [ __ ] Channel
I hate for your channel
where's your [ __ ] Channel Diva Diva
Diva Phoenix Diva man the Phoenix Diva
Dude where's her Channel man oh oh
where's her Channel
what did you go a different time oh
you're gonna go so good
let's open some music
100 Subs man 500 something you have to
protect no one gives a [ __ ] about you
bro
yes
I think it's over right there yeah I
mean I I personally think Bobby can win
the whole thing yeah I do too that's a
wild card that I didn't even think about
Dark Horse
it's like the human embodiment of a
fortune and so yeah
500.
500 Subs man he's like a Viet not
Vietnam flashback he sounds like
that's so good but let's throw it up I
mean we have we have it too if you talk
about it as like a package okay let's
talk about the allegations
and then let me speak oh
that was alone so good oh man that also
we watch a little bit of that I'm sorry
yeah yeah of course
[Applause]
so here is the um talk about the
allegations slightly delayed or no that
was for us so yeah also let it be noted
he's wearing a shirt that says restart
station yeah
cool is that I think it's his March
right or he sells that yeah it's Ricky
oh I knew that somebody's Eddie berwicks
Ricky oh okay
we delay talk about the allegations oh
my God
talk about these this this is
a deadly fresh Scandal yeah dude I'm
sorry I was talking about the let me
speak one that's the one I really wanted
to see
all your levels right now on my screen
no but this [ __ ] was so funny too
because really funny we weren't taking
it seriously at all because it was
stupid uh and then it was it it was
keemstar's audio it was like slightly
out of sync and we just became really
fixated on that and that's all we were
talking about he was trying to react to
like the quote-unquote Scandal and all
we wanted to talk about was how shitty
King's audio was slightly delayed
talk about the allegations
[Applause]
of them trying to you know create
something out of nothing for years and
just picking and picking and we never we
never respond any of their [ __ ] so
he's so frustrated
[ __ ] acknowledge us please he's
literally tugging at his neck weird
restricted also bovie is a great
musician I have to say I have to say
that
you want to play it
I would love oh my God we're opening up
exactly you just opened up Pandora's Box
I've never heard it don't do this during
BLM he put out a song people don't go to
the struggle a billion [ __ ] blacks
oh I can't do this
[Music]
black lives matter
oh but what should that take this so
mean to us
might as well kill yourself
okay
I never thought we talked this is too
much for my brain there's obsessed right
now well y'all are always singing it
back here I'm not even gonna oh you are
oh okay
there's a remix there's a remix that
works so perfectly it's like Queen
somebody said it to another one bites
the dust yeah
which we can't play because it's
copyright but it matches so perfectly
yeah
like rhythmically he knew what he was
doing yeah I think he was probably doing
it to that beat yeah he had to maybe
Thea acoustic I will say I thank you not
to defend it but I think he was a lot
younger whenever he put that out just he
said he regrets it yeah he regrets it
he's embarrassed about it yeah he
definitely regrets it unlike all the
other clips
about that song okay yeah audio is
slightly delayed so I mean there it is
let's throw up the poll Bobby is really
uh yeah it's it's it's a blowout it's a
bob out
75 Bobby 25 ohmish here Bobby
congratulations today is your it is
possibly your gear
unlike George Floyd who oh that joke
sorry
do we have the uh find the link to the
that wasn't even this year I was last
year wasn't it to the bogey thing
black lives matter see now I got in my
head oh my God please don't
die
I cannot
process oh yeah
all right well there that is and so well
that closes the first round that's it we
have the first round winner so
epic here let's take a look
so here's that gonna work now
through the first round yeah everyone's
up to date with these sound bites yeah
so we're gonna move on to the next one
Zach you're gonna play the sound We're
not gonna watch him again maybe only in
the finals we'll watch him okay and then
we're gonna vote just based on the audio
Yeah so let's go ahead
take it to our first
quarterfinal here uh
it's not even quarter five still
whatever whatever you call this round
so Howie
versus fresh and fit go ahead Zach
when my friend Neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
is Wednesday shouts are oh
well there's more fresh and fit ones
picking coconuts and Barbados
so once again
my friend Neil
just keep playing him Zack
keep them going
when my friend Neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it what do we do about it yeah ow
yeah yeah yeah and you can mix them up
and stuff
man it is Wednesday that one really is
tarnished I think by the sound at the
end that's true well that's not clean we
um I think we recite the ending of that
more than the actual sound bites yeah
this is like uh really it bothers me
Wednesday
Barbados you can coconut some Barbados
well it's hard to get clean sound bites
of him because the other guy is always
stepping on what he's saying because it
doesn't make any exactly as he should
get down
all right uh this is a blowout how he's
at 85 he said oh yes the George Floyd
joke by the way before anyone gets mad
was just in reference to Bobby's support
for black lives matter
yeah please don't get mad at me
it's boby's fault all right ending the
pole that's that's a blowout it's not
it's not swaying
okay so moving on so that's a Howie easy
dub easy dub easy clap and how he's
going all the way I think this year but
moving on I think so the uh Theodore
saying what the [ __ ] versus PNP let's go
these are two very simple sound bites
wow Head to Head
let's go
okay let's go
let's go let's go I don't know
let's go back
I mean those are both great Theodore's
got a tough competition I'm voting let's
go just the application of it
you know yeah
it's all right voted let's go let's go
listen not to make you feel bad this
time Milo yeah last time the trenches
Theodore's putting up a pretty good he's
putting up a good fight considering what
he's up against 37 against 63 but p.m
that sound is so cute it's almost not
fair yeah
so funny it's so different then let's go
but uh that's a sweet voice there too
huh BMP
in your darkest time of need the voice
you want to hear is PNP saying let's go
right there
all right that's a that's a win for
let's go 61 percent PMP congratulations
to you my friend
moving on FouseyTUBE
I felt ugly I felt gay
versus love what the heck and dog now
fousey is my Dark Horse
so love you're up against
one of the strongest editors in this
whole tournament I agree yes sir it's a
heavy hitter if I lose this one I
understand I felt worthless I felt
uglier
it tastes like beef jerky okay just
unbelievably strong
God damn Rascal
anyone here from Arizona
time to hit the duster Trail now love
you crushed those sound bites we all
love you as our favorite
America
honored to be even uh put up against
Fouseytube so yeah you put in a great
fight man you put in a great fight those
are my favorite sound bites
there's not many sound bites in the
history that could beat this one you're
up against yeah you beat keemstar that
that's saying a lot
yeah
that wasn't a fair fight either yeah
well I mean yeah well 75 I felt gay
Fouseytube so congratulations I
apologize if people aren't seeing them
because we're going so fast but it was
so one-sided that it wasn't gonna we're
only closing it when it's an easy yeah
if it's close at all we'll leave it up
for a while
as we get closer I think we're gonna
have closer ones we'll leave oh yeah
so moving on we've got uh I'm sorry
about your dad passing away [ __ ] baby
versus Jordan Peterson this one oh my
God that's hard yeah this is going to be
tough I'm sorry about your dad passing
away yeah thank you
[ __ ] thank you Patrick Newman
for the 10 gifts I love you
how you do
you know this is this Gabe's second year
on the show yep for sure yeah because
his second year I feel like is
has been very strong for sound bites
yeah yeah because if you leave behind
the it's Friday baby which you know he
really has his own relevancy yeah it's
impressive and more fans are getting
cameos and sharing it on the subreddit
so that's how we get a lot of the good
ones true yeah okay so Gabe sorry about
your dad [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah
versus
we'll see who cancels who I dreamed I
saw my maternal grandmother sitting by
the bank of a swimming pool which was
also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly
this one alone
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
so it's interesting this one started
very strong in Jordan's favor uh Gabe
has rapidly been catching up though so I
actually feel like we should let this go
for a minute was over 70 and now it's
down to 61. I think the Gap is still too
wide but we can let it go for a minute
just a little bit longer to see if Gabe
still has the momentum any provocative
little monster of about the same age was
standing above her on the same bar when
she should have a child yeah I watched
him move towards her our eyes locked he
slowly and deliberately stepped on her
hands with increasing force over and
over as he stared me down
he knew exactly what he was doing
up yours Daddy-o that was his philosophy
he had already concluded that adults
were contemptible and that he could
safely defy this is a one-year-old he's
too bad
two-year-old that was the Hopeless
future his parents he's old enough to
know about it
to his great and salientary shock I
picked him bodily off the playground
structure and threw him 30 feet down the
field 30 feet
Strange Days
yeah so in my opinion you don't often
get one of the great thinkers of our
time describing in great detail how his
grandmother raped him uh right yeah I
heard someone's feelings but uh here we
have it so to me that's a dub and I
agree Jordan Peterson I'm sorry Gabe we
love you but you are up against the
Titan Jordan Peterson 60 let's not let's
call it for Jordan
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] I pay you won
dude why you ain't so angry I think
again sunshine
all right all right here's the
interesting one Flocka
really needs no introduction no
explanation needed
versus uh suck a little bit of dick
honestly I didn't think I'd get past the
first round
this one I'm a lot more confident
I don't think that Andrew day one's very
strong person no
I don't know that's the game
Bama bottom [ __ ] yes my neck he doesn't
exist shut the [ __ ] up it's unattractive
I'm the one getting plowed
suck a little bit of Dick I'd rather
[ __ ] dudes
okay Zach I know she didn't play Flocka
at all I thought EB was gonna come over
here
oh come on
sorry Zach to make you do that sorry so
you have your fingers
oh good
foreign
it's close but um
close by the way Jordan won you mean
double it's close but flock is winning
and I'm pretty sure flock is going to
close it out with 66 Flocka versus 34
Andrew Tate so
congratulations to uh Hannibal and AV
bird dancing
all right and now oh man the DPI guys
back to haunt you damn
who knows DPI versus Olivia it's
happening hmm
the Olivia Army is strong I'm actually
counting on the Olivia Army to topple
the DPI right now please I think they're
across over I will yeah I agree I think
that
um Mr Mouse sounds really good and
that's why today I will be voting for
him oh come on
I was worried people were associated
more with the people rather than the
sounds but after they betrayed Theodora
I'm okay now I know that that's not
that's that no they stand on their own I
feel like in this case
I would vote for Olivia
it's happening 1 600 DPI I will vote oh
it's close
in guys this is exciting rounds Olivia
stands you got to come through come on
DPI Army let's go no no Olivia stands
don't listen to Olivia
ignore her 52 guys 51 49 it's happening
632 votes we have a lot more votes to
count but early accounting as DPI up
okay now it's got wider 52 DPI yes 48
it's happening this is our closest
on the official count we're at 51 oh
we're at 50 50. we're at 50 50 people
I do though and it's happening can we
hear
um congratulations okay well it's at 50
50. it's 11 500 votes and 50 15. whoa
this is the closest round we've had this
is incredible what's happening I mean
did you hear appreciation
congratulations guys get your boats in
now there's 12 600 voters more to decide
look at this one I just found oh go go
DPI is rallying his support what's
happening 40 200 DPI the [ __ ] Mouse
is coming for my job all right guys 13
700. it's happening takes a quick 51
that's happening it's happening what's
happening
there's only 13 before
votes in guys there's a lot more votes
out there come on get it in oh this is
important it's 51 it's happening DPI was
an early meeting it's literally happened
wow DPI could be losing here today I
didn't see it coming DP I seem so strong
51 it's happening we got 15 000 votes in
guys get those votes in it matters it's
a better sound bite
guys it's down to one percent y'all
better be voting 6400 DPI is it
happening 3 000 to 200 DPI it's
happening 1 600 DPI it's happening 800
P.I it's happening I'm at the bottom
guys get those votes in but it's still
one percent fifteen thousand five
hundred votes 49 DPI 51 it's happening
Hello Olivia go oh what was that one
he's like go go go
that's me rapidly hitting pause and uh
go
go
guys we're gonna have to close this poll
up soon there's 16 000 votes in
49 DPI 51 it's happening we don't see
much movement but
it's still so close steady we're gonna
have to leave it open a little bit long
I think it's happening before it's
happening it's happening it's happening
fans of DPI better get your votes in now
because it's happening
happening I'm waiting for for the next
dump here
taking a selfie for the gifted dump
and remember if you're still in line
they can't turn you away that's right
dumps they're stealing it they got
weights and fish
the votes have really slowed to a
trickle I think let's wait let's wait
for 17 000. all right 17 000 votes it's
got another small dump where it's 16
700.
16 700 votes guys 51 it's happening they
call them dumps it's so funny it's still
staying at the same ratio couldn't be
any closer DPI guys DPI fans out there
y'all are dropping the ball you guys are
16 9 40. next dump it's over we're
calling it
it hasn't moved DPI people get in there
and here comes this is the last dump all
right we're at 17K we're at 17K yeah and
it's 51 percent it's happening wow that
was
two date two this evening the closest
competition it's happening narrowly
defeating DPI but by one
meager percentage there Olivia how are
you feeling about that I am humbled I
feel very grounded right now I feel like
I'm gonna take this win and I'm gonna do
good with it and um Noah centineo once
said it's not what you've done but what
you do with what you've done
I wish you all the best in the pursuing
tournament Chad who's saying it happened
it happened it happened can I either
clean somebody of you saying that it'll
be
thank you no it happened oh it happened
now pretend A Pitbull's rushing you
it happened
it happened we'll work on it like when I
was crying well like when you were
scared and you're like it's happening
so it happened it happened
there it is Olivia moves on and slays
really the unkillable dragon we all
thought deep bi guy was going to run
away with it but uh finally put down by
Olivia moving on we've got ninja I can't
control my goo first Jimmy Lee audio
audio audio
[Music]
that's crazy to me I cannot [ __ ]
believe that yeah one of our mods I
didn't see until afterwards uh but here
now since we're back on it
ramad's blizzard Woofy
I guess and talk to myself
there you go it's video evidence I
cannot believe this someone's gonna sit
here I guess and talk to myself
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] so there you are
you have to catch this yo imagine you're
running for your life you get 360 no
scoped and then he does that after he
shoots you
look this is important so I'm just gonna
sit here I guess and talk to myself
there it is oh unfucking real so Ninja's
got quite a package here
what's up
don't know
and then Jimmy Lee of course hold it I
want to check audio audience
dude we are back neck and neck get your
votes in this is ninja first Jimmy Lee
our very own Jimmy Lee that's so hard
I'm not am I Jewish I don't know for me
the audio audio yeah obviously ninja has
a more comprehensive package and there's
a lot going on there this is yeah but
what Jimmy Lee has is smaller but so
powerful the audio audio and then of
course
and that looks [ __ ] good it's so
close guys yeah we also technically
include with Jimmy uh
[Applause]
it's 49 ninja 51 Jimmy Lee Jimmy Lee
just took the lead what about work with
me 52 Jimmy Lee fomo fomo we don't
really know it's a sound bite though it
doesn't matter he doesn't need the help
because Jimmy took the lead 53 47 ninja
this is not going Ninja's way here
fellas people Balenciaga you never did
that one
what is that I think I heard
that yeah so we it was old but I'm not
intended like it wasn't Jewish
guys I think we can wrap this up because
this is not going Ninja's way too much
continues to move forward
54 to 46 I think we can wrap this up for
our very own Jimmy Leland Jersey Outlaw
that's yeah uh
all right that was a close one man
Jimmy's got happy about that he's got to
be for Pokemon Justice yeah that's right
listen our friend with histrionic
personality disorder must be loving this
right now Jimmy we love you for that as
well he's in Atlantic City right now
um probably not watching probably he's
having a Fanfare he's like afraid I'm
Gonna Be by the coin slots
all right we're moving on here making
good progress up next we've got Hassan's
Adolf Hitler plus laugh package against
our favorite civil rights icon civil
rights icon uh BLM proponents
um
Hitler dude
very funny but now hit us with the bow
blocks
things
intensity that you cannot describe I
feel like this one is going to test
Integrity whoa guys get your votes in
it's close again
stop laughing at Sonic come on
now guys get your votes in because this
is very surprising to me Hassan is
leading with 57 43 I frankly did not see
this I thought Beau blacks was a
contender to win the whole thing yet
here is his son at this moment handily
beating both blocks uh [ __ ] you have
nothing uh uh Hassan says to Beau blacks
oh it's bouncing back though Beau
Black's 45 percent
Hassan 54 it's coming even closer now
get those votes in all you Bobby's Bobby
heads out there
46.
40 is getting even tighter guys the bobi
heads are in the chat and they're coming
out the boat here it's 11 000 votes and
47 percent
send me the let me speak clip baby it's
here in the dark uh here I'll send it
that one's actually knotted you could
say that the other ones were a joke but
this one was
this one's real
he's playing what looks to be like
psychology in an hour and 45 minutes no
that's not an apology there's no apology
[Music]
you [ __ ] and I I can hear what
seems to be crying but uh
or Bobby
you know what Hassan it's kind of
teetering back and forth his son is at
54 I think I think it's solid though
Moby heads this is your last name
46 Beau blacks 500 Subs man come on I'm
shocked I'm shocked I'm in shocked I
gotta I gotta agree between this and
ninja I'm in disbelief
I am in kind of industry this always
happens so there's always upsets in
there
I think it's just sometimes maybe
something is really funny to us in the
office right and so it's like an inside
joke that that poor people really like
Hassan people like Hassan but yeah you
got a separate I'm not saying you guys
are wrong but you gotta separate your
love for Hassan
and compare it to 500 Subs man
[Music]
no but Hassan stones are really funny I
agree no they stand on their own yeah
pull out
guys all right always gets me sorry
Bobby heads
but we had a big L I thought this would
be Bobby's year yeah me too but Hassan I
mean he made it this far I think it is
this year
this is pretty foreign he's not gonna be
happy that he lost a Hassan though huh
well he's gonna be so disappointed with
the Sound by tournament
if anyone cares it's Bobby yeah maybe if
anyone's upset about not advancing it's
him yeah yeah uh Jimmy Lee so Hassan
congratulations Adolf Hitler in the
laugh all right now we're having the
quarterback in my opinion a stunning
upset
oh wow look at what the next round is
this this okay this is the quarterfinal
this is when things really heat up we've
got Howie Mandel is messed up this is
why I'm watching see I just don't know
how y'all didn't rally for Bobby but
okay
congratulations to the sun Howie when my
friend Neil bent over this happened I
mean kind of meme of the year with PNP
again friend of the show
Gotham's finest uh civil protector did
we discover PNP this year
yes yeah yeah that's all this year man
yeah yeah
good man
both of them I would say are kind of
like a meme of the year so go ahead Zach
my friend Neil bent over this happened
somebody know is this covet related so
if it is what do we do about it it's the
lore it's everything I mean it took over
your life like every episode you talk
about it I took it down okay
do you know how many pro how much time
we spent talking about prolapse let's go
For Better or Worse
oh yeah I watched the whole thing but
then again I just love PMP is like
arguably also a meme of the year I don't
know yeah like to me this is a this is a
tough choice PMP let's go that man let's
go a
single-handedly repopulated the
underworld
yeah let's go with a smile and an upbeat
here open the gates of hell
people somebody just donated 80
Australian dollars I believe to say I'm
that she's devastated that the DPI is
out listen I'm shocked by that too Chevy
same Chevy or Chevy the raw cat cone xtd
um you can get one yourself I I you know
they might sell it on your favorite
e-commerce website you know you should
do that while you were uh so um worked
up about this we do a fan service let's
upload all those wav files and just
just call it like uh you know every
girl's fantasy or what I posted as a
video yeah yeah
okay
nothing Well PMP let's go we love you
and we appreciate all you've done for
the world you've made our roads so much
safer oh right and Howie however it
really is Howie's here he's coming in 60
I guess get down okay yes I know but we
won't forget uh PNP 40 you put up a good
fight again
arguably the favorite to win yeah and so
we thank you for a great year and
congratulate Howie for advancing up next
wow this one could go either way Lucy
Tube I felt ugly I felt worthless I felt
gay versus Jordan Peterson package go
ahead Zach I felt worthless I felt ugly
I felt gay I felt that no like that's
just based on what they told me it's
just so good it tastes like beef jerky
wow God damn
no get off the rails dude bra
LMFAO bro in a book The Mob [ __ ] you
mandatory
you may not
baby sad
maybe it's sad why Twitter is insane
yeah just play Rat Hole in the in the
story
seems like a blowout oh I haven't even
voted yet my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bank of a swimming pool
it's hard for me Direct on this one I
haven't voted yet the genital region was
exposed dimly it had the appearance of a
thick mat of hair she was stroking
herself absent-mindedly I she walked
over to me with a handful of pubic hair
compacted into something resembling the
[ __ ] brush pain Grandma has a brush
his face
I raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand she literally forcing herself
on him that is not sexual desire of any
sort
I voted and right now
as much as worthless yeah
go ahead
I felt ugly I felt gay
I felt that no like that just based on
what they told me that's fousey is
winning 59 to 41 you know I thought
about it worthless I listened to both
yeah and as much as I absolutely loved
the Jordan sounds right
the first is like just funny you made
the right choice maybe the maybe
Peterson is kind of getting old because
it's a little bit like we've been doing
it for a while I don't know yay these
are funny I think [ __ ] is uh feeling
more fresh at that moment which is funny
because it's an old ass clip right it
tastes like beef jerky
by the way Elizabeth says she gains five
extra minutes for life every time Ethan
says Rat Hole
H3 podcast is a rat hole Gabriella
graduate tomorrow morning with my
bachelor in psychology
congratulations
congratulations
would you like to when you get a job
Colin will get you fired
just let us know
well congratulations to fousey I think
that was a well-deserved win and a close
one I wonder if he's aware at all
of this resurfacing of this clip here
I I you know who knows probably I'm sure
keemstar [ __ ] is doing about everything
all right if they still friends I don't
know can't start trying to get him
killed in the Box in that boxing match
you forced him to right right so I don't
know if they're still foamy that makes
sense
all right we've got our first like uh
kind of
oh
interesting okay so up next is flakka
versus happening now this is a crew
matchup this is a B versus Olivia yeah
um go ahead Zach
and dude do the the freestyle flockers
too
they're not all on there I I cleared
them out because I don't want to offend
you guys [ __ ] you can't handle the
Flocka no those are good
yeah yeah no I know any of those were
still there
yeah it's happening I'm genuinely voting
for Flocka I feel like it's funny that
strategy has not lost for you yet Olivia
that is true this time I think
for me
it's close actually this is a Flocka
moment
it has a Flocka moment it's hard you
know I mean they're both so special yeah
and it's actually very close it's right
at this moment 6 000 votes and 59 flock
of 41 it's happening so it is very close
especially this late in the game
but I think we can call it for dear ABS
Flocka
and congratulations Olivia you beat a
lot of top contenders so much
yeah you had a good good showing this
year
congratulations AV thank you thank you
all right up next is uh Jimmy Lee audio
adiato versus Hassan Adolf Hitler okay
this is interesting it's a big one now I
didn't expect this song to be Beau
blocks I feel like Beau blacks would
have beat Jimmy Lee but these two head
to head I just don't know go ahead Zach
hold it I want to check audio audio
audio
it's this it's the accent too audio
[ __ ]
cracker cracker cracker
dude
oh my God God damn
those Hassan drops are good holy
holy oh my God
closest yet at least out of the gate wow
wow guys pull out it's time to get those
votes in there's 3 000 casts it is 51
Jimmy Lee 49 Hassan this is a close
close one this could determine the whole
fate of the competition here
we've got
almost six thousand votes and 52 Jamie
Lee audio audio
here we go go ahead Zach just keep
playing keep them coming
I want to check audio whoa audio audio
it just flipped back to Hassan 51 is on
his thumb streaming by the way is he
rigging it
he would do that I don't think so
Hassan is back in the lead 51 Jimmy Lee
who has histrionic personality disorder
is going to be devastated uh it's Jimmy
Lee 49 Hassan 51 uh almost 12 000 votes
passed
this is so close guys your vote oh my
God more than ever whoa
get those votes in
twelve thousand thirteen thousand fifty
one percent Hassan still in the lead
this is so close
on Jimmy Lee stands who did you vote
hold it I didn't even want to say it
it's too painful you know yeah we don't
want to be a bit confidential hold it I
don't want to hurt anyone's feelings you
know yeah when I sent Jimmy the uh Final
Cut of our like Day Out With Him video
to re-upload on his channel the one and
only thing he cut from my edit was the
audio audio part I don't know why he was
he threw that [ __ ] on a t-shirt yeah
exactly yeah and then wouldn't send us
any of it
51 Hassan 49 Jimmy Lee fans of
histrionic personality disorder get your
votes in now come out where's that
psychologist you better voted for the
histrionic [ __ ]
[Music]
wow wow
I'd like to see the percent move at
least once in either direction right
before we call this
it's holding strong
hold it we got 14.5 000 votes in guys
get those votes in now
audio audio audio audio audio audio
audio audio audio audio audio
Jimmy Lee The One and Only Friend of the
show
he's out there sexually harassing
someone right now
cracker
we're about to hit 15K and it hasn't
changed here's what I'm saying I'm gonna
say
this isn't important I don't want to
brush it 16 000 votes and we're gonna
call it okay if we don't thousand more
votes
[Laughter]
[Music]
I feel like all the votes this year are
all neck and neck has it been like this
in the past or we've had we've had
really close ones yeah but like this
consistent though it seems like well now
that once you get a little bit further
into it yeah
we have had like 50 50s in the finals
before
it was pretty excited when it comes down
to it
come on histrionic people out there hold
it
hold it
hold it you never got yeah Now's the
Time because the sun's taking an ad
break so or he pushes it
audio audio audio audio
49 Jimmy Lee God damn it Jimmy get those
bots in here to vote for your ass a dude
bought like 200 000 views per video on
YouTube where you devotes that hold it
49 Jimmy Lee 51 Hassan we are nearing
the 16 000 threshold guys wow
wow 200 away 200.
wow I wish I could see the real number
you know 200 DPI
that might be it oh man this is 100.
It's on is live with 35k people who are
all now spamming go vote for Hassan no
they're rigging it I had a feeling
no that only happened because you just
said it you no they always do that dude
every time we mention him he's like
watching our stream immediately there's
a lot of crossover obviously well anyway
we made it to 16 000. all right uh uh
yeah
wow that's it I am shocked by this he
only just pulled our stream up by the
way yes
limily see you later Jimmy Lee you had a
great year see you later
Hassan is laughing
on Your Grave
damn
well he did you know Jimmy Lee Dude
he did have some big fuck-ups this year
so yeah
but there it is okay this is it guys
this is it there's only four
sound bites left now I saw him watching
this he's gonna win yeah he's watching I
know because like this whole thing
you're encouraging it control now this
is encouraging it uh yeah I'm going
against him next so
GG
well we'll see because the Flocka Army's
out there too all right that you're
looking kind of sad because of uh his
interference
well yeah because they're we there there
is integrity that really matters we've
never had live interference this is
really important
just but what can you do you know what I
mean what can you do
it's a real world we're living in it's
it's democracy
right and I'm at doctors okay he
personally said we got to beat Flocka
Hassan what's going on bro oh no not
looking good here we go
and brought it up this wasn't a thing
and he did he didn't even have the
stream
there's no shot but when you guys are
gonna be playing is sound bites you're
gonna be playing crosstalk he can't even
watch that um
let's go we just got a two-week
suspension
I don't think it's autobaham for Cracker
I think it's uh if you call someone a
cracker specifically oh well I think
it's the hard ER that makes it better
well if no when we get to his turn I'm
gonna call you with the heart of your
heart again
Hassan you're playing checkers but you
know what I'm kind of down because if he
gets banned then they're all gonna come
watch and you know and you don't have to
go on the show over break right if we
get bad luck for long enough
maybe drop that well the nine more will
remember he had to mute the stream oh he
muted it
that's just funny as [ __ ] dude twitch is
wild all right let's keep moving let's
do Howie versus Fouseytube uh now this
this is hard this is huge this is a
battle huge there's no other way to
describe it when my friend Neil bent
over this happened the craziest one yeah
yeah does somebody know is this covet
related and if it is what do we do about
it
ow oh just hook it down okay
go ahead I felt worthless I felt ugly I
felt gay I felt gay gay gay gay gay
well that note like that just based on
what they told me
it tastes like beef jerky yay yay [ __ ]
man
this is so hard in my heart I know who
I'm voting yeah me too whoa 51 49 guys
this I felt worthless this is so close
there's 5 000 votes cast everybody
please get your votes and how he's
leading 51 what are we doing 49 fousey I
felt gay I felt worthless hey
who did you vote for I don't want to say
I don't wanna I didn't know I'll tell
you after the poll closes all right yeah
50 50.
50 you guys wow
250 get your votes in this is on this is
insane this isn't this couldn't be a
closer it's almost unprecedented close
we have to go into overtime penalty kick
ten thousand votes 50 50. I felt gay I
felt worthless he pulled it ahead with
51 and the back happens
now this is Howie's year based on what
they told me this is how he's here for
fusu to overtake him at this late hour
it's truly unbelievable with an old
video what do we do about what do we do
about it
51 fousey 13 000 votes guys I know
there's more voters out there this is
important every vote counts 49 Howie 51
I felt gay Kim Kardashian would like to
say get your [ __ ] ass up and vote
right fit back to 50 50. it's back the
Howie people are rallying in the chat
it's
14 475 votes cast 50 Howie Mandel 50
boost YouTube Pro the prolapse versus
the I felt gay it's the battle of the
Titans I see prolapses in chat the big
red O's obviously that's the sport oh
that's what that is
the pride Flags I didn't put it together
it's a big o-ring baby what do we do
about it what do we do about it okay 15
000 votes and yet here we are at 50 50.
truly unprecedented closeness in the
race number one podcast in the world
thank you oh yeah right
that's a great sound bite yeah it is and
he meant that [ __ ] for God do not want
to get canceled 16
000 votes and yet here we are 50 50 not
one competitor stepping down yay we have
re we have rosebuds in the chat we have
prolapses in the chat we have Howie
Mandel's we have rainbow Flags it's all
happening
when is it fair to say whoever
pulls ahead first like that'll be it I
think so yeah this late in the game yeah
but we're over 15 000 now okay or does
that mean they both
Advance how and then you you have like
three you have like three at the time we
need a winner yeah there can always be
one hair back people and I'm I'm Banning
this that's a good point though bending
the rules but then you have two I know
you have a head versus head bracket oh
well he's gonna be the winner
but you'll have two and then the next
winner will finalize and then you have
three
competing for one minute add more
another round
not another round but like from the next
bracket you'll have three choices
I think it's gonna flip there's almost
17 000 votes him how we meant out
Fouseytube standoff 50 50. wow
the worthless yeah I can't believe it
okay 50 for this long
this is unprecedented we've never seen
this happen
it tastes like beef jerky
I felt gay
but worthless yay nothing ugly and
YouTube literally doesn't tell you the
vote total so I I don't know which one
is in the lead we're up to 17 000 votes
so there's been a lot of votes cast here
it's still 50 50 y'all if you haven't
voted
get your vote in now it matters more
than ever but democracy only works if
you guys vote ow
we're gonna have to do what I said
because oh just I I'm not ready to call
it though it's just you know what I mean
it's too close I'm fine people you know
it's just too close I think it's
officially a draw like you need to you
need a process
for a scenario of a draw you wanna do a
recount I mean we never thought that we
would need a [ __ ] we would ever have
a draw here right you could bring a wild
card back Mr DPI heck no technically I
will point out
you see how there's a outline around
Howie I believe that actually means that
I don't see an outline
well I do it's because you wrote it for
it now oh yeah
I I have as a poll Creator Howie's has
an outline around it I believe that
means that how he is technically in the
lead even though it's 50 50. you see
that let me look
I mean it's on screen too I guess you
right you guys can't see it because it's
hidden behind oh yeah we can see your
screen right or this like oh you just
have to trust me yeah I see what you
mean it's highlighted yeah so the one
that's highlighted is technically the
one that has more votes right now even
though it's statistically it's too too
close to call too close 18 000 votes
this is unfreaking real dude Fouseytube
versus Howie the two kings of Industry
to a recount I kind of like the three
shows final that you lost all right so
so Ruby play next to me again okay so we
advance both of them basically and then
we move on to the next bracket the flaw
covers Hassan yeah we'll have a winner
there that will advance and then you
have three sound bites competing for the
final spot instead of two yeah three
shows yeah why not that I don't know how
I feel about three oh wait wait it flips
yep how we took it it's over okay it's
over people Howie
congratulations so guys
wow I'm excited to announce fousey put
up a hell of a way better yeah ever did
in the boxing ring holy he did yeah I'm
excited to announce that after 18 500
boats how we took it by one percent wow
and you know
I personally I voted for fousey as much
as I oh wow and it's really I am part of
that story yeah it's like in my heart I
felt that I felt worthless I felt ugly I
felt game that's just what they told me
so when you said that to me I thought
you meant you're voting Howie I voted
Howie I voted I voted [ __ ] and I love
Howie like I said I love
but
I don't know but there it is the people
spoke
how women people shouting rig people
shouting bad pull all this
you're just like your little trumpers
your little maggas you can't handle
waiting fish Dan weights and fish
yo whatever happened to last year's we
had a great one the uh they're stealing
it they're stealing it
I mean we still use it all the time
all right so one more uh semi-final and
then the listen guys Howie is in the
finals is is Hassan still watching by
the way he's on a different video right
now but I think his chat is his chat is
still gone so let's try to get sneaked
in here while he's uh watching something
else and if you notice he turns it on
just Spam cracker
okay you have my permission to call Dana
cracker baby okay
no I'm ready
all right Flocka versus son
here we go I'm trying to keep this as
Fair as possible now I'm not trying to
discourage anybody from voting for
Hassan don't get me wrong I just want to
keep the vote as Fair as possible
because in democracy yeah we're saying
it's homophobic that we didn't that we
didn't pick I agree
yeah because I'm an ally I'm sorry
I'm an ally right yeah and I proved my
allyship today yeah oh my God all right
hit me with the sound bites all right
let's go listen we all love Hassan but I
think it's sort of becoming H3 versus
something
I know don't say it go ahead no that was
it I'm just saying he has his army we
have control how strong we are
Crackle
[Laughter]
let's see oh it's 50 50 again this is
unreal oh my God
he just
brought it up this is not fair
the Integrity of this election is being
called into question
this is democracy I mean what yeah
ballot stuffing bro ain't democracy
pull out I've seen how they do they pull
up those trucks and the back of the
YouTubes headquarters two thousand mules
or whatever however many [ __ ] mules
they have well no matter whatever
Hassan's doing to regular selection
it is still neck and neck 50 50 flakka
versus Adolf Hitler Hassan wow it
couldn't be any closer frankly uh 12 000
votes cast guys get your votes in it
matters more than ever
I can't believe it was even 50 50 to be
honest that doesn't mean you blow out so
I'm honored thank you guys
in the chat now oh [ __ ] Hassan wants to
win maybe you better say some words
he's got three thousand I got 3 000
mules you better drop the cracker
nah I can't do it to him yo it's already
up to 15 000 do you think he'd actually
get in trouble if you called I really I
think I wouldn't I'm pretty certain it's
calling someone a cracker versus just
saying crap bro Hassan took the lead so
you can still say it
I can't do it 51 is on flock of 49 it's
not too late to go down a cracker baby
might be banned he has to call Dan a
cracker oh good point luck
yeah I don't know it's great I don't
care about that but it would be funny
that's hilarious ma'am he said he's H he
said he's H3 family he's instead in the
chat he is he's family I agree
right now
well we've got 16 000 votes
49 Flocka 51 Hassan this is close as it
possibly gets here today how are you
feeling baby
I feel like people always wonder what if
what if Hassan Chad didn't see that we
were alive
what were the results have been could
flock have gone the distance
they would have seen it nobody was even
thinking that until you started doing it
come here literally it wasn't happening
until you brought it up of the biggest
Tournament of the year the pawn wouldn't
[ __ ] know he was in it
and then immediately people went over to
him and said hey because they noticed at
the same time me were in the
quarterfinals Hassan doesn't notice he's
in the biggest [ __ ] event of the year
17 000 49 holding strong
51 Hassan laughing laughing all the way
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] up about his turn this
family apart so do you feel do you feel
that this election wasn't fair love yeah
bro what the [ __ ] typical American [ __ ]
dude
it's not fair bro so do you have a
remedy just do what do we do do we just
accept it or do we storm uh storms
Zach Lewis Live January 6. listen I
don't have any problem with him winning
personally but I'm just saying if you're
concerned about the rigging foreign
I
also don't want Flocka to win because I
know it will break
our boys that is true I don't want it to
win either because of that I would kind
of like to say that that works so hard
and for him all of his accomplishments
to be overshadowed by the stupid flock
but Zack's genius
I think that this whole competition is
Zach's like everything all the sound
bites are here except the Flocka I know
but I don't know if it won that's like
Dev exactly would you be devastated
Flaco one would it hurt you I wouldn't
be devastated no I mean look I it's my
job to you know pull all these different
sound bites and you know it would hurt a
little bit I mean a little maybe yeah I
saw comments leading up being like it'll
be funny to imagine Zach's reaction like
it'd be funny to [ __ ] with them well the
debate is over because Flocka is now
down by two percentage Yeah it's 48 to
52 we're gonna call it that is Hassan up
uh this is the top of this of the
subreddit oh that's beautiful in case
you're feeling bad about the flockas
that's a beautiful thing right there
look at that is this an AI this [ __ ]
looks I think it is
all right never mind it's not beautiful
but he's still the champion he's still
the champion of the sound bite there it
is you see that
not quite sure it looks like he's about
to be shot by through a Star Wars except
for some [ __ ] I don't know what's up
people gotta start getting their mail-in
ballots ready though for Howie like yeah
preparing get your [ __ ] ass up Sarah
thank you for the uh Dono my husband and
I speak and sound bites to each other
from the show since the beginning the
show's gotten him through some really
hard times good I'm glad you didn't tell
me what those hard times were the trauma
dump on me I appreciate you people today
what the [ __ ] it's Friday we gotta bring
this down [ __ ] is this Sarah you know
what you're doing they're alive that's
all we need to know yeah
I'm alive
here we go in the front Advanced uh
Hassan okay this is it guys is it
this is the 2022
sound bite Olympics finals we are joined
by Howie Mandel my friend Neil bent over
and this happened does anybody know is
this covet related and if it is what do
we do about it
my friend Neil bent over this happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it it's
interesting that we find how we hear he
met a lot of resistance along the way
if we look bad back at his path he hit
man it is Wednesdays he beat let's go he
beat I felt ugly I felt worthless I felt
gay and here he now finds himself in the
final a true competitor in every sense
of the word congratulations to Howie
just for making it here today
and now let's look at Hassan's path here
first going up wait is that the no that
goes back more doesn't it yeah
uh so wait which one was um
Howie up against first
Steve will do it right which was also
really good let's follow Hassan's path
to the finals here
first round liver King don't talk about
my wife in the context uh
clash of the primals coming up next he
beat his son now this was one of the big
upsets it shocked the hell out of me
Hassan overcoming Beau Black's 500 Subs
man who was a favorite to win the whole
damn thing he moved on he beat Jimmy
Lee's audio audio audio
moved on yet again to decimate a B's
Crown Jewel Flocka
and here we are find ourselves
at the end of the year
and we'll scroll over a bit yeah
in the final round you know I just
remembered something about the Flocka
just a quick side note I was the one
that actually originally pulled it
oh you did yeah okay
um I forgot what we were talking about
but it had to do with Waka Flocka and I
was a fan of the Eric Andre show and AP
got the Flocka bucks no I'm not taking
any credit away from him I found a lot
of sound bites too I'm just exactly no
I'm just trying not to use that team
effort well hold on Zach pulled Flocka
Maca didn't win for the record or dirty
lot no no I'm just saying like I I have
no harm against it whatsoever but it's
more it's expanding on because you guys
were saying should he be like
insulted or like right no he feels like
he no need to be insulted he literally
made it in though exactly yeah no it's
we're it's all family her yeah there's
no bad blood whatsoever
Lauren says my 21st birthday is on the
day of the live show
but I couldn't get any tickets I'm 21.
so can I get a happy birthday happy
birthday Lauren there it is again 21
[ __ ] you thank you every damn time it's
crazy all right I'm gonna start the pole
this is it oh wait hold on hold on hold
on no not yet not yet we gotta play the
videos for the finals okay okay it's
important that we give all the full
context possible so let me open my show
Doc
here we have Howie Mandel which was the
first video of the whole tournament I
can't watch this one it's super blurred
out you played in you've got it on
standby
bent over this happened does somebody
know is this covid related and if it is
what do we do about it wait you're
asking him to play out yeah yeah play
the video
no he doesn't have the video don't want
the rose I'll play the audio I'll play
the audio okay who's got the rose
it's just like he's got the rose there's
no sound associated with it you guys
played the same thing ready three two
one when my friend Neil bent over that's
pretty good actually does somebody know
is this covid related and if it is what
do we do about it dude it's so funny
it's Howie Mandel he literally posted a
giant prolapsed anus on [ __ ] Tick
Tock it does not get better bro listen
and here we are Hassan
uh serving it up and Teddy fresh looking
great three you know who was around in
the 1900s
[Applause]
oh I love that tank
there it is oh man literally said
Adolf Hitler Hassan
[Laughter]
and that's the take that I happen to
agree with uh
is uh Kanye convinced me of that he made
roads and microphones
parody parody parody microphones
disavowing disbelief
satire you know
what was funny about what I said is that
he didn't actually invent roads and
microphones right irony irony alert
I'm Jewish
Hassan says he's putting weights in fish
guys
so fans of Howie before we put this pull
up just know your backs are against the
wall you are fighting for your life this
is D-Day all right we are pulling up on
the shores of Hassan and we have to vote
like our lives matter because they do
now I'm not saying Hassan doesn't
deserve the one he shouldn't win I'm
just saying I know what's going on out
there I know what's happening cracker
and that uh Hassan has an advantage
going in I wish you would have rode like
that for me
for Howie I did I was telling you you
had to fight I kept telling you to tell
call Dana Crasher
I said crackle like 20 times during your
vote yeah well I don't want to get
banned
right we're calling him a cracker
see I'm still doing well it's too late I
tried my best for you pull up the pole
guys
okay here we go
wow there's no way or something
how we met down
let's go with perhaps the greatest Tick
Tock of all time it was up for 17 hours
viewed millions of times
a giant [ __ ] prolapse on a
family-friendly app 17 hours my friend
Neil bent over and this happened doesn't
anybody know
is it covered related and if it is what
do we do about it
where's the sun who
are you team Hassan because he beat you
no I'm just team Hassan he's just a
great guy
okay dude wait what's happening it's a
blowout
hold on let me load out it's blown out
like Neil's [ __ ]
oh uh
now it's on Whose family we had a great
years of leftovers his last infectious
you know Adolf Hitler dude is a what
beloved sound bite
but here's Howie up against Hassan
they've both met stiff competition but
here today
I'm comfortable calling this
give it some time
I mean we're almost at 15 000. you know
what how are you gonna get he's playing
the victory music his audience is now
watching all right let him vote let him
vote because Dale bent over this
happened I'm saying does somebody knows
everybody don't waste the party got it
cut it cut it oh God damn it cut it
listen Howie is had the year of a
lifetime is that okay it's it's moving a
little bit 63 percent Howie 37 Hassan I
don't even think
I don't think they have a chance even if
they wanted to rig it that's what I
think at this with this difference there
is no going against the Howie prolapse
meme because even his fans know that's
bigger than all of us yeah it's bigger
than we are
some ideas are bigger than even somebody
just said even Hassan's chat is spamming
the uh the ogre you can't beat it you
can't beat it it's unreliable he said
that he's getting his back blown out
here's the thing though it's a blow
about
here's the thing their Howie's path was
arduous and he almost lost I think the
real battle took place between fousey
and yeah that could have been the final
two easily Audrey says this was so fun
thanks for another great year cheers
love you thanks Audrey so did we call it
we got it so guys I think that I think
we're gonna call it play the music
Howie Mandel
what do we do about it what do we do
about nothing my God
nothing
I kind of want to call her Howie
oh no
he's gonna be like when will it end yeah
we're finding new ways every week
yeah you know you're ruin his weekend I
think this because I think it's been the
Howies year we usually when a zombie
wins
it kind of gets retired yeah
if you think back of shout out to the
family I mean we're still here but it's
not the same yeah right oh I never know
letting him not live this this is never
going away
we'll never forget there's two things I
never forget 911 and Howie Mandel Pro
and let's be real me fousey and Hassan
always knew be a white guy that takes it
oh now oh my God he's Jewish he's Jewish
so if you want to make it a uh okay
Adolf Hitler dude am I right yeah
okay let's see those b-holes in [ __ ]
chat guys
Hassan's demanding a recount
oh please demand is nuts and bow blacks
it wasn't even close I really want to
give a shout out to Bobby
I thought those two had a really strong
chance of breaking through but
ultimately
oh God I'm not I wasn't I was being
serious
well now I am but yeah ultimately this
was Howie's Game to lose and uh he took
it down he went the distance he went the
distance this is exciting this feels
good it would be kind of sad if fusier
or how he didn't win I think to be
honest well the thing is yeah I voted
for foosi yeah right me too honestly
yeah it was one of them though
wow this is exciting guys so there it is
uh Howie Mandel my friend Neil bent over
this happened this is the year is this
covid related it sounds sweetie and let
let it be the year of the prolapse 2023
we will find some other uh bodily
function to obsess over for the whole
year because I think
I think I'm prolapsed out and I think a
good chunk of the audiences too while
our live show might get a glimpse of
some prolapses oh my God I think that's
legal well we'll find out what do we do
about
um by the way Hassan is whining and
complaining on Twitter he says God that
we closed the polls early he will storm
the compound and demand a recount
it wasn't even close if it was well
exactly but it's like did he erase it if
it oh he was he got shamed out of it
embarrassing it got uh deleted for Miss
info right yeah Elon deleted it
oh [ __ ] there it is all right uh let's
get uh the hell out of here because this
is a four and a half hour oh my God
that's the tradition so guys once again
I want to thank everybody
we had a lot of gifted today a lot of
subbies a lot of uh gifts I thank you
all so much for your thank you
was that one on there it was it was in
the uh honorable mention yeah oh
honorable mention yeah I remember
hearing it today
yeah guys it's been a great year and I
just thank you all so much for making it
all happen and oh the new tweet was an
update all right let's see what kind of
misinfo you're still spreading
look at this
is that Biden and Trump yeah sorry buddy
because serious he looks
maybe next year Hassan will have another
year of a leftover
maybe we will get banned again so guys
we will be back on Tuesday at 8 00 p.m
PST for our final show beer
yes it's gonna be an awesome show so I
hope you guys can watch it live but it's
gonna go up like a normal video so it's
all good and to all the wonderful
members who joined today and continue to
support us I will continue to make see
you next Tuesday podcast for peace and
love throughout the break
we come back
January
16th yeah
January 16th
so have a great holiday have a great
weekend and we'll see on Tuesday for our
final show all right and uh wow what a
year huh congratulations amazing
you may have lost millions of dollars
with staples but you have won our hearts
yeah absolutely
Priceless that's priceless
all right guys
thanks everyone for watching we'll see
ya
on Tuesday
[Music]
when my friend Neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
[Music]